par l'europe tout d'abord le break site
à l'heure où la commission européenne
adresse une lettre de mise en demeure au
royaume uni pour non-respect de l'accord
de retrait comment voyez-vous le
dénouement des négociations sur le
partenariat futur nos exigences sur la
pêche la loyauté de la concurrence
l'accès au marché la circulation et la
gouvernance seront elles prises en
compte
sans mon prêt en cas de nos deals dans
le même temps l'europe est parvenu à un
accord inédit sur un plan de relance le
21 juin dernier grâce à l'entente du
couple franco-allemand depuis des
blocages sont survenus en lien avec
l'exigence de respect de l'état de droit
pour bénéficier des fonds européens
quand ce plan pourra-t-il être finalisée
et sur quel contenu
le conseil européen des 1er et 2 octobre
a pris les décisions importantes en
matière de politique industrielle et en
matière de transition numérique
notamment en posant les fondations d'une
réglementation pour superviser les
plateformes internet
il s'agit d'un sujet d'intérêt pour
notre commission dont une mission
d'information est en cours sur les
géants du numérique
par ailleurs au sujet du projet annoncé
par le sud avant d'émigrer n de refonte
du règlement de dublin sur l'accueil des
réfugiés
va-t-on enfin vers en droit d'asile
comment vers une harmonisation du droit
d'asile et des conditions d'accueil des
demandeurs d'asile en europe
enfin nous savons monsieur le ministre
que vous voulez nous dire deux mots sur
l'alliance pour le multilatéralisme qui
rencontre un bon succès voilà monsieur
le ministre
quelques-unes de nombreuses questions
que nous nous posons mes collègues en
aurons d'autres à vous poser après votre
intervention liminaire
je vous êtes maintenant la parole
monsieur le président et je suis ravi de
vous retrouver mesdames et messieurs les
députés
je voudrais d'abord vous demander
monsieur le président de transmettre à
votre président de mes meilleurs voeux
de rétablissement et vous dire aux uns
et aux autres que ça fait plusieurs
semaines que nous sommes vus et comme
vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
président il s'est passé vraiment
beaucoup de choses en particulier au
mois d'août et dans la première partie
septembre mais même au début du mois
d'octobre de l'actualité tout à fait
était extrêmement chargé je vais essayer
de répondre à au moins une partie de vos
questions parce que sur l'ampleur des
sujets que vous me proposez je pense
qu'on pourrait tenir tout l'après-midi
et où de la soirée mais comme vous
l'avez dit je vais revenir la semaine
prochaine peut-être même une autre fois
après pour compléter mon propos s'ils
n'ont pas pu aller jusqu'au bout
aujourd'hui
cette réunion intervient dans un
calendrier diplomatique chargé puisque
vous l'avez rappelé le conseil européen
s'est réuni il ya quelques jours et un
nouveau conseil européen va avoir lieu
mi octobre
donc il ya une intensité de relations
entre les membres les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement des vingt-sept
et puis parallèlement c'est peut-être
passé un peu inaperçu mais enfin je
voulais le rappeler ici devant votre
commission est en train de s'achever
ce voyage fait maintenant l'assemblée
générale des nations unies
c'est une assemblée générale des nations
unies un peu particulière puisque c'est
une assemblée générale en visio
néanmoins ces tenues
néanmoins et c'est au virtuel si vous
voulez mais néanmoins et ses tenues
cela permit à vos chefs délégation de
120 chefs d'état du gouvernement de
prendre la parole et j'ai pour ma part
une expérience très très singulière
d'avoir assisté à un conseil de sécurité
des nations unies en visioconférence en
virtuel me trouvant moi-même à amman un
autre à new york un autre à berlin et on
a ici comme cela de pérenniser de
manière la plus forte possible
le multilatéralisme parce que je
considère que la participation
importante qui ait eu lieu à cette
assemblée générale qui généralement
donné lieu à beaucoup de débats à new
york cette participation néanmoins est
le signe d'une volonté de maintenir des
espaces de dialogue que dans un monde
qui en a bien besoin et cette assemblée
générale nous a permis aussi d'avoir de
tenir des réunions pas plus tard
qu'avant-hier sur les sujets de crise
que nous allons évoquer que ce soit une
réunion sur le liban sous l'alibi sur la
rca et sur d'autres sujets de conflits
qualité en ce moment
vous vous rendez bien compte que la
coopération internationale le
multilatéralisme l'action collective et
sont plus que jamais nécessaires dans
cette période et nous avons inscrit
puisque vous l'avez évoqué une réunion
de l'alliance pour le multilatéralisme
que nous avons créée il ya un an
le ministre des affaires étrangères
allemand et moi-même à new york nous
fêtions six fours utilisés pour la
première année c'était c'était avant la
corona la copie de 19 et cette réunion
sur le multilatéralisme a eu un vrai
succès puisqu'il y avait 70 ministres
affaires étrangères a participé en
visioconférence à ces deux rencontres
l'aller 2 2 ou 3 remarque je voulais
faire ce l'assemblée générale des
nations unies parce que elle s'est tenue
même si c'est ça ne s'est pas senti très
fortement raison de conditions
particulières de cette rencontre
vous m'avez interpellé sur de nombreuses
crises je vais essayer de revenir sur
chacun des sujets que vous avez évoqué
d'abord sur le liban oh comme vous
l'avez rappelé le président de la
république s'est rendu juste après
l'explosion sur le port de beyrouth le 6
août
et de nouveau le 1er septembre je
m'étais moi même rendu une première fois
avant d'accompagner le président de la
république à beyrouth à la fin du mois
de juillet il y à cette catastrophe et
je veux redire que sur la réponse est
cette catastrophe la france c'est
vraiment très mobilisés que ce soit au
niveau de l'état au niveau du centre de
crise du quai d'orsay mais aussi au
niveau des collectivités territoriales
des ong
il ya vraiment eu un accompagnement très
très significative de solidarité que je
voulais souligner ici il ya
véritablement un pont aérien et maritime
qui s'est mise en place et qui a été
apprécié par les libanais par le peuple
libanais ce que nous avons insisté à cet
égard je voudrais leur dire ici pour que
l'ensemble des des capacités de secours
humanitaire que nous mettions en place
s'adresse directement au peuple libanais
ou aux ong libanaises et ne passe pas
par le dispositif étatique et nous y
avons veillé de très près puisque les
l'ensemble des des contributions
physiques qui ont été affectés or au
liban étaient centralisées sur
l'hippodrome qu'il ceux qui connaissent
eux bayrou était juste en face de la
résidence de france
la raison se dépeint et donc c'est à
partir de là que se faisait la
distribution auprès des acteurs de
terrain pour l'aide humanitaire
immédiate mais nous avons pu aussi tenir
une réunion spéciale des nations unies
le 9 août dont quelques jours après
l'initiative de la france pour mobiliser
des financements et il ya eu financement
de 250 millions d'euros qui ont été
mobilisés à cette occasion ce qui a
permis d'élargir les contributions des
uns et des autres et d'avoir une vraie
mobilisation internationale
nous avons pu constater sur place à
beyrouth non seulement le 6 mais aussi
le 1er septembre comme nous sommes
retournés sur place je suis même rendu à
marseille
quelques jours auparavant pour assister
au départ d'un bateau pour le liban
puisque c'était le thème de l'opération
qui était une opération co organisé
entre mon ministère les collectivités
régionales et locales du sud et de
régions sud et la compagnie cma-cgm tout
ça montre un état d'esprit une
solidarité forte de la population
française à l'égard de la population
libanaise ce n'est pas le moment
d'arrêter et je pense que il faudra
poursuivre les efforts dans cette
direction parce que la situation au
liban l'état de la population est très
préoccupant il a en plus de tout cela le
l'arrivée de lakovic 19 qui le liban
était en partie épargné jusqu'à présent
mais malheureusement la pandémie se
diffuse assez rapidement tout cela
nécessite à la poursuite d'un
accompagnant extrêmement extrêmement
vigoureux que nous allons nous-mêmes
organisés dans les jours qui viennent
puisque se tiendra comme conformément
aux engagements que nous avions pris se
tiendra au courant du mois de novembre
une réunion de soutien humanitaire au
liban pour passer à la deuxième étape la
première étape c'était l'urgence
la deuxième étape se lasser la
reconstruction et la france avec une
nation unie sera à l'initiative
à cet égard au delà de ça mesdames et
messieurs les députés
il ne faudrait pas que cette catastrophe
occulte le grab le drame politique qui
existe au liban et l'exigence que nous
portons mais c'est pas que nous la
france c'est aussi le groupe
international de soutien du liban que
j'ai réuni à deux reprises depuis un an
dont il représente 2
beaucoup d'acteurs qui sont soutien du
liban et souhaite que le liban prennent
les mesures nécessaires pour sortir de
l'ornière et d'abord dans une urgence
faire en sorte que les réformes sur
lesquelles tout le monde est d'accord se
mette en oeuvre avec un gouvernement de
mission une espèce du gouvernement de
combat qui puisse faire en sorte que ce
serait serré fort ne soit pas uniquement
dans les discours mais dans l'action
c'est ses orientations là que le
président de la république a proposé aux
forces politiques libanaises ou le 1er
septembre dernier le premier ministre
qui avait été nommé à l'époque le
premier nystad yb a tenté de composer un
gouvernement sur ces bases il n'a pas
abouti à cette hypothèse est aujourd'hui
sommes dans un gouvernement de gestion
provisoire qui ne peut pas durer
et donc il importe maintenant que sur la
base d une feuille de route sur laquelle
les autorités
les différents partis politiques
libanais se sont mis d'accord sur la
base cette feuille de route un
gouvernement d'action soit constitué
pour l'intérêt du liban
le risque est en jeu ne modère pas mes
mots
le risque étant si ça ne se fait pas la
dislocation voire même la disparition et
donc pour ma part je suis extrêmement
mobilisée sur ce sujet il nous faut agir
en permanence en ce sens et une nouvelle
réunion ii
groupe d amis du liban du gie ce qui du
groupe international pour de soutien au
liban se réunir dans quelques jours pour
de nouveaux reformuler nos souhaits de
mise en oeuvre de cette logique là qui
est partagée au moins dans les discours
par toutes les formations politiques
identifiés ou au liban mais
l'aboutissement ne se fait pas et la
population aujourd'hui et dans
l'angoissé dans l'inquiétude
que dire les choses comme ça dans le la
fois la tristesse parfois la révolte et
qui ne s'exprime plus dans les rues dans
la mesure où le corona virus empêche
toutes sortes de manifestations
mais la réalité est très très très
préoccupante
voilà où nous en sommes à cet instant il
ya eu des déclarations ici là qui ont
été faites mais l'essentiel c'est que la
feuille de route sur lesquels les
groupes politiques se sont mis d'accord
puis cette mise en oeuvre par un
gouvernement d'action qui jusqu'à
présent n'a pas pu être au rendez vous
il appartiendra au président aoun de
proposer un nouveau premier ministre
susceptible de réunir cette convergence
en tout cas soyez sûrs que la france
n'abandonnera pas le liban et les
libanais et en ce qui me concerne je
suis particulièrement vigilants sur ce
point et patrimoine attentif à tout ce
qui s'y passe vous m'avez aussi
interpellé monsieur le président sur le
mali vous avez rappelé que pendant l'été
courant du mois d'août il y a eu un coup
d'état que nous avons condamné
initié par un groupe de colonel menée
par le colonel rigaud ita il ya eu d'une
part un coup d'état et d'autre part
quelques temps après la démission du
président et brahim boubacar keïta qui
aujourd'hui s'est retranché à abidjan
nous avons condamné cette ce coup d'état
et nous avons souhaité que la communauté
économique des états d'afrique de
l'ouest puissent mener les actions de
médiation pour aboutir à la mise en
oeuvre d'un certain nombre de principes
que la cedeao mettait en avant avec
raison d'abord une transition qui soit
courte
ensuite une un transfert du pouvoir de
la junte des autorités civiles et
ensuite la mise en oeuvre d'une charte
de transition permettant d'aboutir à une
nouvelle logique une nouvelle dynamique
malienne cela a été initiée par le
médiateur de la cedeao qui était
monsieur goodluck johnatan c'est-à-dire
l'os pour ceux qui connaissent l'ancien
président du nigeria qui a eu plusieurs
missions de à bamako car les chefs
d'état et gouvernement aussi de la
région se sont mobilisés pour aboutir un
résultat est à ce jour il y a eu des
avancées que je voulais soulevé soul amy
avec vous d'abord président de
transition a été nommé i les civils il
s'appelle le monsieur bada os ensuite
ensuite un premier ministre monsieur
moctar ouane a été nommé le 27 septembre
c'est un personnage ancien ministe
affaires étrangères dans un gouvernement
bien antérieure mais qui est
relativement respectés il a composé son
gouvernement assis inclusif et
le avant-hier 5 il ya deux jours et hier
la cedeao
étant donné que les autorités maliennes
se sont dotés aussi d'une charte de
transition
la cedeao a considéré qu'ils pouvaient
maintenant qu'on pouvait maintenant
rentrer en discussion et en
reconnaissance de nouveaux dispositifs
cela a été aussi le cas de l'union
européenne et c'est notre cas et donc
puisque hier la cedeao a pris cette
position nous allons accompagner cette
démarche et j'ai l'intention de me
rendre prochainement au mali pour
continuer la meilleure insertion du mali
dans le dispositif de la cedeao et du g5
rencontrer les nouvelles autorités et
souhaité que la charte de transition se
met en oeuvre et soient totalement
respectés
du coup les comptes les sanctions qui
avait été initiée par les pays voisins
parce qu'il ya eu des sanctions des pays
voisins contre le mali vont être sont
levés depuis hier et ce devrait
permettre d'avancer dans une nouvelle
donne nous sommes conscients de la
nécessité d'accompagner la cette
transition pour aboutir à dans 18 mois à
de nouvelles élections mais tout ça ne
doit pas nous conduire à relâcher nos
efforts dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme et là pendant toute cette
période il n'ya l'opération berkane cc
poursuivi la dynamique de pau a produit
ses effets avec des succès militaires et
une certaine confiance est en train de
revenir entre les différents les
différents acteurs nous allons donc
poursuivre en ce sens et nous
déplacement à bamako permettra de faire
un point avec l'ensemble des partenaires
du g5 sahel vous m'avez aussi interrogé
sur la méditerranée centrale et
orientale tout ça c'était aussi au mois
d'août c'était
un mois très actif dans les crises
internationales à la fois le liban la
méditerranée orientale et le mali dans
la même semaine c'est beaucoup
il y à une montée des tensions en
méditerranée centrale et orientale
c'était une en particulier en
méditerranée orientale
c'est une vieille affaire parce que
cette zone a toujours été une zone assez
tendue sur en particulier la définition
des frontières en particulier des
frontières maritimes essentiellement des
frontières maritimes
mais c'est devenu plus tendues récemment
en raison de la découverte de potentiel
gisements de gaz dans la zone est
évidemment de candidats pour
l'exploitation se plier à menez as rome
mettre en question les zones les
délimitations le maritime et la
délimitation des zones en dans le
respect normalement des accords dits
accords de montée gobeil c'est à dire du
droit maritime international que la
turquie ne reconnaît pas et là nous
avons été amenés à agir
nous sommes amenés à agir pour la
sécurité et la défense de nos intérêts
et les actions unilatérales qui ont été
menés par la turquie porte non seulement
atteinte à la souveraineté de la grèce
et de chypre mais porte atteinte aussi à
la souveraineté de l'union européenne
dans son ensemble nous avons réaffirmé
dans cette affaire à plusieurs reprises
aurait pu le lire comme moi ou le
constater après nos initiatives
nous avons été amenés à plusieurs
reprises a réaffirmé notre solidarité
avec athènes et nicosie
il est essentiel que les états membres
de l'union européenne maintienne un
front uni face à la volonté d'ankara de
délimiter des zones des juridictions
mérite maritime par la seule politique
du fait accompli en contradiction avec
le droit international
il ya eu des tensions
il y a eu aussi un discours de fermeté
lors du dernier conseil européen la
semaine dernière
vous pouvez y avoir des tentations de
certains pays d'union europe de l'union
européenne une attitude plus plus molle
mais je pense que le résultat de ce
conseil ont été conformes à nos
principes
c'est à dire les atteintes à la
souveraineté des pays membres doivent
cesser et que l'union européenne est
prête à identifier toutes les options y
compris dissuasive y compris des
sanctions contre la turquie
si celle ci s'engage pour une
désescalade avant le conseil européen de
décembre
ça produit quelques effets dans la
mesure où un dialogue sur cette question
particulière s'est mise en oeuvre avec
la grèce elle le retour au port d'une
avic du navire turc aux rouches raïs qui
était jusqu'à présent des flots déployés
au large de l'île grecque de
kastellorizo c'est un signal
encourageant il ya eu un deuxième acte
qui est le retour annoncé d'un bateau
qui était dans les eaux chypriotes mais
il en reste encore un donc nous sommes
pas au bout et la fermeté du discours je
pense a permis cette évolution président
de la république s'est entretenu
fermement avec le président erdogan et
le fait qu'il y ait des pourparlers
exploratoires qui sont en cours est
plutôt une bonne chose mais il faut que
nous gardions la fermeté et l'unité dans
cette affaire je me réjouis aussi que la
fermeté française et était reconnu dans
sa justesse après les manoeuvres style
qui ont été effectuées par un bâtiment
de la marine turque
c'était je vous avais déjà parlé de
sages pour la dernière fois que l'on
qu'on s'est vus à l'encontre d'une
frégate française le courbet qui
pourtant ne faisait que rien d'autre que
qu'elle exécutait les hordes de la
chaîne de commandement de l'otan pour
surveiller les flux des goûts en
méditerranée j'ai pu le rencontrer le
secrétaire général de l'otan et les
mesures qui ont été prises pour éviter
de renouveler ce type de comportement
me paraît ce utile d'autant plus que
lors du conseil des affaires étrangères
de la dernière semaine d'avant les
vingt-sept ont adopté à l'unanimité des
sanctions pour violation de l'embargo à
l'encontre d'une compagnie aérienne et
de deux compagnies maritimes dont
l'armateur que notre culture pendant du
chirkin qui était le bateau qui avait
été identifié dans l'opération que je
viens de citer
voilà où nous en sommes sur la
méditerranée orientale
il ya un calendrier fermeté des propos
un rendez vous et c'est dans en fonction
de ce calendrier là que les turcs
doivent prendre les initiatives
nécessaires il ya des discussions qui
sont en cours avec avec la grèce je vais
rencontrer demain mon collègue grec pour
aboutir à une délimitation des
frontières qu'ils soient partagés par
les uns et par les autres
mais sommes que là pour l'instant donc
il ya besoin d'être toujours très ferme
sur la clarification de la part d'ankara
est l'étape suivante de notre côté
consisterait à constater qu'il retire
l'ensemble des bateaux de la zone
économique exclusive de chypre je passe
au karabagh je n'ai pas fini bélarus et
la libye
et puis
la russie sur le haut-karabagh l'acier
la situation du conflit à cette heure et
est très grave et c'est la raison pour
laquelle notre mobilisation politique
est très forte car comme vous le savez
nous avons un mandat la france de la
part de l'eau et c'est eux depuis 1994
un mandat de valider à la fois le cessez
le feu qui s'est produit à ce moment là
en 1994 parce qu'il ya eu des conflits à
la fin de de l'union soviétique entre
entre les deux les deux pays sur le
statut dieu du haut karabagh je précise
pour ceux qui l'ignoreraient c'est tout
à fait respectable de l'ignorer que
c'est une enclave de population
arménienne au milieu de l'azerbaïdjan
donc qu' il un conflit il ya eu un arrêt
en 1994 il ya eu une ouverture de
discussions engagement de d'ouverture de
discussions entre les différentes
parties sous la co responsabilité des
états unis de la france et de la russie
ce qui nous a amenés hier soir ou demain
matin
faire un communiqué hier soir lundi soir
à faire un communiqué qui vous a
peut-être par une surprenante signé à la
fois de mon collègue pompéo de mon
collègue lavrov et de moi même
c'est rare que nous fassions des
communiqués à 3 de ce format là pour
demander l'arrêt des combats départ est
doté l'ouverture de négociations avec
les trois coprésidents de ce qu'on
appelle le groupe de minsk
c'est un peu c'est un communiqué d'une
grande fermeté à l'égard des uns et des
autres souhaitant qu'il soit écouté il y
a un nombre important de victimes
civiles pour des avancées territoriale
faible de la part de l'azerbaïjan
puisque les herbes et jean qui a initié
le conflit pour un gain territoriale
relativement faible mais le conflit
continue en cours ce matin et nous nous
souhaitons que chacun comprenne que son
intérêt est d'arrêter immédiatement les
hostilités sans conditionnalité et que
l'on ouvre effectivement une négociation
sous le parrainage de réputés pays que
j'ai indiqué tout à l'heure
la nouveauté c'est qu'il y a une
implication militaire de la turquie qui
risque d'alimenter leurs oeufs
l'internationalisation du conflit ce que
nous ne souhaitons pas et donc nous
avons fichons très très clairement notre
volonté de faire en sorte que ce
compromis qui consiste à dire je renonce
à toute conditionnalité
on venait en respecte le cessez-le-feu
en rentrant négociations puissent
aboutir à une solution positive partagée
même si ça prend un peu de temps pour
tout vous dire c'est une somme en
relation journalière avec les uns avec
les autres en ce qui me concerne et je
sais que c'est aussi la même chose pour
d'autres pour mon collègue russe et
aussi pour l'adjoint de du de secrétaire
pompéo pour l'instant nous n'avons pas
abouti ça fait onze jours que ça dure
il y aura des réunions demain à genève
il y aura d'autres réunions lundi à
moscou et nous formulons le voeu que
cela puisse aboutir à l'ouverture de
négociations on ne peut pas commencer
par dire je veux bien je viens de
cessez-le-feu mais à condition que
connaissent pas ce qu'on s'en sort pas
donc on arrête on se met à table on
discute et on prend le temps de discuter
dans la durée pour se mettre d'accord
sur une citation qui permettrait aux uns
et aux autres de vivre normalement je
vais vous dire aussi quelques mots sur
la libye vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure
monsieur le président les risques de six
réalisations de la libye c'est une
réalité que j'exprime depuis déjà
plusieurs mois les ingérences étrangères
et singulièrement l'afflux de
mercenaires notamment depuis la syrie
les violations de l'embargo alimente la
dégradation de la situation et ses
ingérences sur le fait essentiellement
de la turquie mais aussi de la russie
pour une partie et tout cela représente
une menace directe pour nos intérêts de
sécurité de souveraineté et donc si
aujourd'hui il y à une trêve d'une trêve
ce n'est pas un cessez le feu cessez le
feu c'est négocier une trêve c'est un
constat s'il ya aujourd'hui une trêve
dans la sur la ligne syrte joufra ce qui
est plutôt positif tant que cette trêve
ne transformant cessez le feu
elle est toujours fragile et nous
mobilisons avec nos partenaires
européens singulièrement avec les mets
italiens et les allemands pour à la fois
consolider la cessation des hostilités
et puis engager une discussion d'abord
militaires dans le cadre des accords
dits accords de berlin qui avait fait
l'objet d'un accord général de
l'ensemble des acteurs que s'est tenue
en bois 2 au mois de janvier
il ya un comité militaire mixte qui
s'appelle le 5 + 5 militaires qui doit
permettre d'aboutir tranquille va
progressivement à ce que la traite se
transforme en cessez le feu et sur le
dans le domaine économique la situation
par contre là évoluent assez rapidement
puisque un premier accord sur la levée
du blocus des terminaux pétroliers a été
trouvé et cela peut représenter un
développement positif
si les revenus engendrés par la
réouverture progressive des terminaux
pétroliers bénéficie à tous les libyens
et c'est le partage de ces ressources
qui fait l'objet de discussions en ce
moment qui reste assez compliqué et par
ailleurs par ailleurs des discussions
parallèles ont eu lieu à la fois à
montreux en suisse et à bouznika au
maroc avec différents acteurs pour faire
en sorte qu'il y ait un dialogue entre
les différentes parties
à l'initiative d'un côté des nations
unies l'autre côté des autorités
marocaines
cela peut être positif parce qu'il
faudrait aboutir à un accord interlibyen
inclusif entre l'ensemble des acteurs
c'est ce qui est en train de se chercher
en ce moment avec l'autorité des nations
unies et qui pourrait permettre
d'aboutir un processus de paix de
stabilité durable en intégrant les trois
aspects que je viens de vous indiquer
sommes aujourd'hui en discussion avec
les pays voisins de la libye avec
lesquels nous parlons nous avons des
canaux de discussion historique
je pense à la tunisie l'algérie l'egypte
le tchad et le niger en particulier le
soudan maintenant un petit peu pour
pouvoir organiser une rencontre des
voisins de la libye qui accompagnerait
le processus dit processus de berlin
c'est plus calme que sanaa était
peut-être un peu plus positif que ça le
fus est en tout cas nous sommes tout à
fait engager dans ce dans ce processus
est en fait le fait qu'il n'y ait plus
de conflits en ce moment du conflit armé
est de nature à peut-être permettre d
ouverture positive
quelques mots sur la biélorussie puisque
vous avez reçu madame chicanos callas ce
matin j'ai pour ma part rencontré à deux
reprises depuis le début de la crise de
biélorussie qui s'est aussi passé au
mois d'août il y a quatre points majeurs
que nous lui avons indiqué déjà lorsque
nous sommes vus à vilnius la semaine
dernière 1
nous refusons de reconnaître à monsieur
lukashenko la légitimité politique qu'il
revendique
à la suite du scrutin du 19 août qui les
habitants de la bio russie considère
qu'ils ont été volées de leur vote
démocratique
donc nous refusons de le reconnaître ce
qui veut dire que aujourd'hui les les
ambassadeurs de l'union européenne parce
que les autorités bélarusses avaient
demandé aux polonais l'ambassadeur de
litanies banc de se retirer de de minsk
il ya une solidarité des ambassadeurs
européens
his day hertz est donc tout le monde
s'est retiré il ya plus en basse teneur
de l'union européenne la protestation en
ce moment auprès de minsk profusion de
reconnaître monsieur loukachenko comme
même si c'est lui-même auto investi le
24 septembre dernier
nous poursuivons notre soutien à la
mobilisation démocratique le fait seul
fait que madame team sky à soient reçus
ici fait partie de cela
nous refusons toute forme de répression
contre la société civile que nous
continuons à soutenir jeudi nous et les
européens parce que nous avons à cet
égard un dialogue permanent une relation
permanente entre les vingt-sept nous
sommes contents complètement sur la même
ligne et nous avons décidé pour
appliquer tout cela et pourrait aller
dans cette direction
lors de notre réunion de la fin
septembre une
décision de sanction qui s'applique
désormais puisque quarante personnalités
biélorusse responsable de fraude
électorale et de pratiques de répression
ont été sanctionnés à commencer par
louise de l'intérieur de monsieur
lukashenko donc il y a une volonté de
faire en sorte que les libertés
démocratiques liberté d'expression
liberté de la presse il battait
manifestation soit soit respecté le
soutien euros à la protestation qui
s'est manifesté la volonté d'un dialogue
inclusif
nous sommes prêts à voir l'océan joue un
rôle utile dans cette crise nous avions
le sentiment que c'était aussi la
position de la russie
nous pensons que c'est la seule solution
pour s'en sortir qu'il y ait une
médiation qu'ils soient initiés par par
l'eau et c'est eux qui est l'organisme
tout à fait adéquat pour mener cette
négociation
je ne sais pas j'imagine que madame dati
cnops callas vous a dit la même chose
que ce qu'elle a dit au président macron
que ce qu'elle a dit aux ministres
affaires étrangères européens qu'elle
avait rencontré il ya quelques jours
avant sur le fait que ce n'est pas une
crise géopolitique et c'est une crise
interne la biélorussie c'est une crise
démocratique interne
elle répète à plusieurs reprises qu'elle
n'est pas ni pour ni contre la russie ni
pour ni contre l'europe mais elle est
pour la biélorussie démocratique et
c'est comme ça qu'il faut interpréter
cette situation politique en belgique
sur la russie je ne vais pas interrogé
sur le sujet mais je vais quand même
parler un peu delà de la sphère navalni
parce que c'est une affaire grave
c'était aussi au mois d'août tout était
au mois d'août finalement là la très
grave tentative d'assassinât commise le
20 août dernier l'encontre de lexie
navalni nous a amenés à demander la plus
grande clarté de la part de la russie
sur les conditions dans lesquelles cette
tentative était intervenue car qui mieux
que la russie peut nous dire pourquoi et
comment un opposant politique russe de
premier plan
a pu faire l'objet d'une tentative
d'assassinât sur le territoire russe par
le biais d'un agent neurones
neurotoxiques de qualité militaire de la
famille des novices choc qui était
développé uniquement par la russie nous
avons aussi par nos moyens propres
confirmé que comme le haut si l'on fait
nos collègues allemands que c'est bien
une arme chimique de la famille de nos
vies chat qui a été utilisé pour
empoisonner monsieur navalni nord il ya
deux actes lourds qui se conjuguent
d'une part une tentative d'assassinât
d'un opposant et d'autre part
l'utilisation d'un produit chimique est
condamné par la communauté
internationale y compris par la russie
et l'organisation internationale
organisation de l'interdiction des armes
chimiques l'oeil ac a rendu un avis hier
sur la composition de ce produit est le
pro de la vie est conforme à ce que l'on
dit et les allemands et nous la brenne
et nos propre laboratoire et danser dans
ces conditions nous disons parce qu'il
sonne nous savons depuis hier nous
disons avec l'allemagne que la
clarification par la réussite cette
situation est indispensable et qu'à
défaut clarification il faudra en tirer
les conclusions en lien avec nos
partenaires européens doit dire
d'ailleurs qu'à cet égard nous avons été
totalement en phase convergence
d'actions des changes avec nos amis
allemands et
j'ai d'ailleurs été un peu surpris que
monsieur road again
le président de la commission des
affaires étrangères d'allemagne et cru
bon dans un article qui est paru tout à
l'heure dans la presse du soir comme on
dit et puis remettre en cause cette
synergie d'action et je pense qu'il aura
intérêt à lire le communiqué commun de
mes séries comme assez de moi-même qui
sortira dans une requête à la fois à
berlin et à paris pour montrer notre
position à l'égard de la faire navalni
ça ne veut pas dire il ne faut plus
parler aux russes mais ça veut dire
qu'avec la russie faut être à la fois
ferme et ouvert sommes ouverts au
dialogue mais fermes sur nos convictions
et quand il ya les actes cette ampleur
on le dit et on le fait savoir
et je dirais que même le dialogue est
d'autant plus nécessaire que nous sommes
dans une situation conflictuelle parce
que c'est à ce moment là qu'on peut
essayer de se parler peut-être de
manière raide mais au moins d'une
manière claire nous avons été amenés
dans ce cadre après cette affaire
navalni à reporter la réunion du conseil
de coopération franco-russe qui devait
se tenir la semaine dernière sur les
questions de sécurité mais ça n'empêche
pas la nécessité de poursuivre ces
échanges sans naïveté en transparence
avec nos partenaires européens et avec
un seul objectif renforcer notre
sécurité et la stabilité de l'espace
européen
enfin vous m'avez interrogé sur hong
kong
j'aurais vous dire aussi toute notre
préoccupation c'est que comme je vous
l'avais dit
et comme nous pouvons le craindre après
l'adoption de la loi sur la sécurité
nationale le 30 juin dernier l'autonomie
d'hong kong et les libertés garanties
par loi fondamentale ainsi que le
principe un pays deux systèmes sont
manifestement remise en cause
les arrestations de manifestants
290 personnes ont été arrêtées le 6
septembre dernier alors qu'elles
manifestaient pacifiquement contre le
report des élections législatives je
vais y revenir
l'arrestation de personnalités de
l'opposition je dois wang en particulier
arrêtée puis libérée sous caution pour
avec le motif de participation des
rassemblements ou de collusion avec des
forces étrangères pression à l'égard de
la presse arrestation de gym il ay
fondateur du quotidien d'opposition
toute une série d'actions nourrissent ce
constat inquiétant depuis le 30 juin
d'autant plus que les autorités ont pris
la décision de reporter d'un an les
législatives initialement prévues le 6
septembre du fait du zèle de la
situation sanitaire donc face à ces
volets ces évolutions nous avons agi
avec nos partenaires européens
en adoptant un paquet de mesures le 28
juillet dernier
articulée autour de plusieurs points
dans des actions en matière de visas de
mobilité de ma d'exposer d'exportation
de matériels sensibles mobilisation de
programmes et de bourse d'échangés
universitaires et de renoncement à la
ratification de l'accord d'extradition
qui avait des signes et en le 4 mai
dernier ne calmait 2017 pardon entre la
france et la région administrative de
hong kong
donc nous assurons fermement cette
détermination et nous le faisons aussi à
chacune des occasions qui se présentent
à nous pour évoquer notre nous
inquiétudes de notre fermeté à cet égard
j'ai reçu mon collègue chinois en
juillet fallait pas longtemps
non c'était en doute
pour lui dire profiter de cette visite
de cette visite qu'il a effectué pour
lui dire tout cela j'ai aussi abordé
tout ça est toujours aussi abordée dans
la conférence entre l'union européenne
et la chine qui s'est tenue le 14
septembre à en visioconférence et le prg
et le président du conseil européen et
la présidente de la commission et la
présidente madame merkel ont eu
présidente au delà en exercice a eu
l'occasion de développer l'ensemble de
ces questions liées à hong kong en
particulier mes ouïghours aussi puisque
j'ai évoqué ce soit hier à l'assemblée
nationale avec beaucoup de force
voilà monsieur le président je ne sais
pas si vous voulez je continue mais
c'était c'était là je crois que
l'ensemble des crises j'ai fini le mois
d'août mais j'ai pas le haut karabagh
c'était à moi de cette cité au mois de
septembre mais s'avoue montreux que ben
on a beaucoup pas mal d'occupation en ce
moment j'ai un point de satisfaction
néanmoins des vous de vous voir sûrement
est de constater que au niveau européen
par contre ça va beaucoup mieux je suis
assez optimiste je sais pas si on aura
l'occasion d'en parler cette fois parce
qu'on s'est pas vu depuis l'aube depuis
longtemps vous le dirait monsieur prénom
s'il faut que nous en part la semaine
prochaine la semaine d'après je trouve
que l'europe pendant cette période
difficile y compris sur les crises y
compris sur les crises a appris des
dépositions forte et l'évolution de
l'europe incite à l'optimisme mais c'est
quand même un moteur important dans la
vie de ministre des affaires étrangères
confrontées à tous les défis que je
viens d'évoquer
voilà merci de votre attention et puis
et puis je vais essayer de répondre aux
questions si j'ai pas eu l'occasion de
le faire dans mes propos introductif
préfère faire ça parce que je peux tout
à fait monsieur le ministre
merci merci pour vos propos liminaire je
sais nos collègues
très passionné par les questions
d'actualité donc je serai une petite
exigence c'est d'être concis dans vos
questions pour que tout le monde puisse
me poser parce que j'ai beaucoup
d'orateurs a passé donc je me
demanderais comme d'être un peu con si
pour obtenir dans les trois minutes
maximum pour les orateurs et deux
minutes pour deux minutes où on va pour
deux minutes pour les orateurs
je donnerai non mais je rigole je rigole
nous allons nous allons non nous allons
nous allons pouvoir alors donner la
parole à tous les collègues mais je vous
demanderais cette exigence de tenir dans
les trois minutes pour les orateurs et
si on n'a pas si tout le monde ne peut
pas passer
monsieur le ministre nous a bien que la
séance de la semaine prochaine sera
dédiée au budget de prendre quelques
temps pour répondre aux autres questions
voilà donc si je peux répondre par
paquet c'est plus facile pour tout le
monde
voilà plutôt que de répondre alors peu
douché pas toujours tous les cas tous
les six et si vous voulez bien la partie
européenne que j'étais pas que j'ai à
peine évoqué parce que tu as fait une
ampleur des sujets je pourrais faire la
semaine prochaine si vous voulez bien où
la fois suivante parce qu'il y aura un
conseil européen encore le 16 et il y
aura la question du break site qui va se
poser très très vite qui fait partie des
problèmes par contre mais qui arrive
très vite le sage a peut-être parler du
bric site la semaine prochaine pour voir
ce qu'on voulait merci monsieur le
ministre
merci alors je donnerai la parole pour
la république en marche mais réclament
aux petits réglages merci monsieur le
président merci monsieur le ministre
c'est toujours d'un très très grand
intérêt de vous entendre
je voulais rappeler que le 22 septembre
le président de la république a livré
dans un discours à l'occasion de la
soixante quinzième assemblée générale
des nations unies une longue feuille de
route qui répond à sa vision des
relations internationales à l'heure de
la crise sanitaire et économique
et cette vision s'articule
surtout autour de la notion de
souveraineté celle de l'union européenne
qui doit être consolidée pour exister
entre les états unis à la chine est
celle des autres peuples de la
périphérie russe au moyen-orient dont la
france veut soutenir les aspirations
légitimes sans ingérence donc sur les
différents conflits que vous avez
mentionné le président a rappelé les
positions françaises les principes
d'action de la france doivent être
claires at il dit le respect des droits
souverains des peuples la consolidation
des états de droit de leurs moyens
d'action l'exigence est la
responsabilité pour assurer la mise en
oeuvre effective des décisions actées
sous l'égide des nations unies
et ce préambule est en fait au sein du
groupe de minsk la légitimité des
revendications territoriales au regard
du droit international
le rôle des membres du groupe de minsk
dans lesquelles figure la turquie je le
rappelle l'impact dans nos
circonscriptions de ce conflit et puis
le rôle plutôt modérateur de la russie
mais si vous le permettez moi je
voudrais plutôt axé ma question sur la
situation des civils
puisqu'on sait que après plus de 10
jours de combats entre les forces
séparatistes arménienne l armée
azerbaïdjanaise c'est quand même surtout
la population civile qui étaient touchés
puisque c'était pas la carte la capitale
du karabagh est la cible de frappes
d'artillerie qui force la population à
se terrer et choucha une ville de 4000
habitants était à son tour atteintes par
des tirs azerbaïdjanais je passe sur le
bilan numérique parce que il n'est pas
réellement fiable mais aussi la question
des déplacés 50% de la population
auraient été déplacées soit 70 milles à
75000 personnes dont 15 rbds et jane et
arméniens s'accusent mutuellement de
viser des civils et démentent
systématiquement les succès militaires
annoncées par le camp ennemi
parmi les ong le comité international de
la croix rouge informe que des centaines
de maisons et d'infrastructures clés
comme des hôpitaux et des écoles ont été
détruites ou endommagées par les tirs
d'artillerie lourde et par des attaques
aériennes et amnesty international
dénonce l'utilisation de bombes à sous
munitions interdites depuis 2010 par une
convention internationale
donc pour conclure mes questions d'abord
quelles mesures peuvent être prises pour
protéger épargner les civils ainsi que
les infrastructures civiles comme le
droit international humanitaire
l'obligent deuxième question la
neutralité que nous affichons est elle
tenable
quand l'agression avait caractérisé que
les bombardements visent les civils et
puis une question subsidiaire peut-être
et pour conclure il ya un embargo un
embargo sur les armes qui étaient
demandés par l'ouest chez eux alors
qu'ils vendent des armes aux deux
parties la russie israël qui aurait
vendu 825 millions de dollars d'armes
entre 2006 et 2010 9 la turquie la
france point d'interrogation je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre
merci chers collègues pour les
républicains
guy teissier 6 merci monsieur le
président merci monsieur le ministre
d'être venu une fois encore je dirais
jusqu'à nous pour faire un vaste
panorama de la situation mondiale qui
est pour le moins préoccupante
je pense monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues qu'il est indispensable de
mettre un certain nombre d'éléments
historiques en perspective
j'attends que mon collègue soit assise
merci en perspective ceci pour mieux
comprendre ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
et je pense aussi permettre une sortie
de crise je pense monsieur ministre
qu'il faut rappeler que 90 % du
territoire arménien a été confisqué par
les turcs dans l'histoire
première chose deuxièmement le peuple
arménien a subi le premier génocide de
notre ère avec un million et demi de
gens des portes et massacré et cela
compte dans les mémoires et dans
l'histoire que nous vivons encore
aujourd'hui je pense que le président de
la république a eu des mots forts pour
reconnaître sans équivoque que ce sont
les azerbaïdjanais sans aucune raison
apparente
qui ont attaqué la le haut karabagh
larzac et par voie de conséquence
l'arménie donc cette agression à 0 turc
envers les arméniens mérite je pense de
prendre des sanctions fortes à l'égard
de la turquie et du régime dictatorial
d'aliev je pense ce même que la turquie
retrouve ses vieux démons d'un
expansionnisme tout azimut
on les retrouve en syrie on les retrouve
en libye on les retrouve vous l'avez dit
monsieur le ministre en grèce et là ils
sont avec les azerbaïdjanais qui sont
turcophones comme eux mais l'azerbaïdjan
vous le savez comment était une terre
turque dans un temps enfin pas si ancien
que ça jusqu'à la guerre de 14
jusqu'après la guerre donc la question
de l'exclusion de la turquie de l'otan
me semble être opposé à aujourd'hui
est ce qu'on peut considérer que la
turquie peut être encore membre de
l'otan à ce jour étant très souvent face
à ses alliés traditionnels ou à nos
alliés traditionnels ainsi que je pense
que nous devons vous l'avez pas soulever
monsieur le ministre
et ça m'étonne mérite de fortes
sanctions économiques
on l'a pris en les a prises et vous
l'avez dit par contre avec la russie à
propos de l'invasion de la crimée donc
je pense que il est important dans un
premier temps de vouloir avoir ces
sanctions à l'égard de de la turquie
dont la france où l'avait rappelé est
membre du groupe de minx depuis bien
longtemps mais il semblerait monsieur
nice que ce statu quo convenait à tout
le monde aux russes aux américains et et
nous avec
mais nous n'avons jamais pris une
position tranchée et je crois que
maintenant il est vraiment temps de
reconnaître
de reconnaître d'une main d'une manière
avec avec l'eau avec la communauté
européenne j'en termine de vraiment de
après les sanctions de reconnaître que
le karabagh est une terre arménienne le
karabagh et depuis la nuit des temps
occupé par 90% en arménien et vous le
savez mais mes collègues je pense aussi
je reconnais c'est un caprice de staline
qui a annexé le karabagh à l'azerbaïdjan
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui j'en ai terminé
héros ça va bon et donc qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui nous connaissions ce
conflit je pense que nous grandir you
are connaissant le quart marc comme une
telle énergie pour la paix dans cette
région
merci cher que si mes chers collègues de
votre patience merci chers collègues
pour le mouvement démocrate est
démocrate apparenté michel fanget merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre dans votre exposé vous est
largement revenu bien sûr sur la
question libanaise et sur la question
décisive de la france je souhaiterais
prolonger un peu cette discussion et
nous avons déjà eu l'occasion de dire la
relation de la france au liban est
ancienne et repose sur une histoire qui
mêle tout à la fois les dimensions
culturelles spirituelles économique de
la vie des peuples la profondeur de
cette relation s'est construite au fil
du siècle autour d'une idée fixe la
coexistence pacifique de minorités temps
ethniques culturelles et religieuses
c'est là une des particularités du liban
dans cet orient compliqué et c'est ce
que nous devons préserver beaucoup est
entrepris par la france et par le
président de la république qui s'est
personnellement investi pour dénouer ce
noeud gordien or chacun sait qu'en la
matière c'est là une révolution
politique que nous devons appeler
changements politiques changement des
pratiques changement de la gestion d'un
pays à la dérive
il est heureux qu'en cette période
l'amitié des peuples français et
libanais survécu et suroît même se
renforcer et nous savons que c'est à ce
niveau celui de la volonté populaire que
l'essentiel pourra se faire alors
monsieur le ministre de questions
simplement
dans ce contexte nous ne pouvons ignorer
le rôle fondamental que joue les
confessions religieuses à ce titre
pensez vous que l'objectif affiché par
le prix
dans aoun d'aboutir à une constitution
laïque soit atteignable si oui quels
vous paraît qu'elle vous paraissait être
les étapes indispensables pour y
parvenir et deuxième question de ce
point de vue le saint siège s'est
beaucoup prononcer sur le liban qu elle
vous paraît être l'utilité de ce qu'il
est coutume d'appeler la diplomatie
vaticane dans le contexte libanais et
comment estimez-vous son influence sur
place je vous remercie monsieur nist
merci chers collègues pour autre
conclusion
merci merci pour les socialistes et
apparentés
alain david oui merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre je
souhaiterais pour ma part vous
interrogez concernant taiwan
comme vous le savez sans doute dans le
cadre des travaux de la commission nous
avons passé en revue les situations dans
de nombreux pays à travers des auditions
éclairante de nos diplomates et
d'experts sur la crise sanitaire
récemment nous avons été impressionnés
par la façon dont ce pays proches de la
chine entretenant de fortes relations
économiques commerciales et souvent
familiales avec le foyer de l'épidémie a
su contenir ses conséquences ils ont
évidemment bénéficier de leur expérience
face à la précédente épidémie de strass
et de la qualité de leur système de
santé mais leur stratégie globale a
semble-t-il été remarquable en tous
points leur permettant de limiter les
contaminations les hospitalisations et
les décès à des niveaux records sans
pour autant obérer leur économie par des
mesures de confinement impactante taiwan
demande en vain pour l'instant a
bénéficié d'un simple poste
d'observateur à l'om s afin de partager
son expertise et de faire avancer la
lutte contre cette pandémie
que pense la diplomatie française de
cette demande
merci merci beaucoup chers collègues
pour agir ensemble mg/l gradins
pardon merci monsieur le président la
réforme du franc cfa est une étape
préalable dans la feuille de route du
projet de monnaie unique de la
communauté économique des états
d'afrique de l'ouest les pays de la
cedeao ont évoqué l'an 2020 l'année 2020
pour la création de l'éco mais sans
fixer de calendrier précis
en effet réuni le 7 septembre à niamey
les chefs d'états et de gouvernements de
la région ont contacté le report
inéluctable de la mesure il ne reste il
ne restait plus que quatre mois pour
lancer la monnaie unique de la cedeao
comme l'évoqué régulièrement les textes
depuis 2015 un délai bien court alors
qu'il restait encore à créer la banque
centrale fédérale a précisé le régime de
change de la nouvelle monnaie sans
compter les nécessaires démarches
administratives et informatiques liés au
changement de devise et à la fabrication
de pièces et de billets alors que le
calendrier électoral monsieur le
ministre à venir dans plusieurs pays de
la région s'annonce très chargé je pense
la côte d'ivoire au burkina faso à la
guinée au niger est peu propice pour une
telle réforme quand celle ci selon vous
vers at elle véritablement le jour
en filigrane quel regard portez vous sur
ce grand cycle électoral ouest africain
qui va rythmer la fin de l'année dont
les enjeux sont conséquents par ailleurs
monsieur le ministre une question locale
pour moi je ne cesserai jamais de louer
les efforts humains techniques et
financiers consentis par le quai d'orsay
pour le rapatriement de nos compatriotes
bloqués à l'étranger
il y en a en algérie déjà plus de 50
milles qui ont été rapatriés certains
d'entre eux qui ont des véhicules sont
toujours monsieur le ministre
bloquée et se trouve face à une à
l'option suivante soit abandonné leur
véhicule en douane pour rentrer en avion
pour revenir le chercher à l'ouverture
aux maîtres leur véhicule sur un cargo
et rentrer par avion patienter ou
attendre l'ouverture des frontières ou
un bateau de rapatriement quelle
solution s'offre à eux
peut-on leur envoyer des bateaux et pour
finir monsieur le ministre une dernière
question vous avez parlé de la libye
j'ai eu le plaisir de rencontrer madame
le fraper du hellen notre ambassadrice
sur place est ce que on va réouvrir
notre ambassade en libye
merci merci beaucoup chers collègues
pour eu des indépendants meyer habib son
on n'a pas le sens meilleur juste trente
secondes dans le sombre de la vie
mandela très bien très bien entendu
c'est bien oui tout est d'accord
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre si votre propos liminaire mais
la faillite économique politique morale
du liban l'un nombre de responsables on
connaît c'est le hezbollah le credo par
tous les dieux les véritables
organisations terroristes mafieuse à
l'ept à la solde de l'iran qui a pris en
otages du liban depuis encore place
nouveauté ce bout là bas il pas prononcé
leurs propos liminaire monsieur le
ministre la semaine dernière l'explosion
et 200 morts la dévoiler le journal die
welt sont directement responsables mais
être là qu'a reçu des centaines de
milliers de tonnes de nitrate d'ammonium
de l'iran auprès de 1014 la semaine
dernière les le premier ministre a bien
dévoilé pour assembler généralisation
d'une idée des pot'arts actuellement
actuellement encore près de dépôt de gaz
en plein beyrouth l'hommelet ce vol à un
système de terreur ou reprendre même les
termes chef de l'état emmanuel macron
c'est l'attentât je vous rappelle
évidemment où draka 59 par actuelle
c'est l'attaquant pas de marks spencer
c'est les attentats de la rue de rennes
si les attentats qui ont fait des guides
et plusieurs 13 morts pendant paris
c'est le terrorisme antisémites à buenos
aires tout récemment encore en bulgarie
c'est les crimes de l'humanité en syrie
c'est un réseau mafieux transnationales
qui rackettent qui trafiquent drogue etc
pourtant monsieur le ministre vous avez
déclaré encore il ya peu de temps sur
trois en france inter il y à l'ouest
militaires que nous condamnons et il ya
eu un problème politique avec lequel on
parle alors je parle sans langue de bois
je crois qu'il ya une c'est une faute
à défaut nalité de faire la distinction
entre les deux branches nos collègues
vous en parler de l'allemagne tout à
l'heure à l'instar de l'allemagne qui
ont mis fin à la distinction factice
entre d'ailleurs que le hezbollah ne
veut maintenant que le hezbollah
militaire et politique
monsieur le ministre est-ce que alors
que là comme je les ai essayé de le
prouver la responsabilité du hezbollah
apparaît au grand jour est enfin enfin
nous allons faire une différence entre
arrêter de faire une différence entre
eux le hesbollah politique et le
hesbollah militaire ça c'est la première
question est très rapidement la seconde
question alors que nous sommes en plein
procès charlie et qui perd cacher un
lien qu'on sait qu'il n'a pas eu lieu
ces procès de l'attentât de la rue des
rosiers qui a eu il ya 38 ans on a
appris tout récemment je vous avais
interrogé il ya un an et demi là dessus
il ya 40 parlementaires qui ont cosigné
une demande de commission d'enquêté sur
cette question alors que les normes
région accepté d'extrader un des quatre
assassins après le magnifique travail du
juge trévidic
est ce enfin pourrait imaginer que nous
demandions l'extradition des trois
autres criminels dont un se trouve à
ramallah et deux en jordanie le
président de la république avait des
macros en a parlé il bouge question qui
a été une question aussi tabou pendant
des dizaines d'années
enfin vous pensez qu'on pourra avoir un
les traditions et de le procès de ces
assassins dont merci merci vocaux chers
collègues pour la france a soumises
clémentine autain oui je vous remercie
ma première question pour le ministre
concerne orale l'enjeu des ouïghours
alors je sais que vous nous avez dit
qu'il y avait une question qui avait été
posée par l'une de nos collègues hier
aux questions d'actualité mais
il est arrivé que sur des sujets que
vous avez abordé aujourd'hui il y ait eu
des questions sur lequel vous avez
répondu
et par ailleurs il me semble que les
termes que vous avez utilisé en deux
minutes hier ne suffisent pas à donner
une vision du gouvernement français
votre propre position sur ce qui se
passe en chine avec les ouigours où il
s'agit là quand même d' un massacre qui
est d'une ampleur et d'une violence
inégalée probablement aujourd'hui à
travers le monde
donc il me semble que dans l'ensemble
des interventions puisque vous balayer
la situation internationale je suis très
étonné de voir que cette question soit
si peu abordée dans vos propos
liminaires et que par ailleurs il ne
vous a pas échappé qu'un comité de
solidarité de députés pour le peuple
ouïghour s'est constitué vous avez sans
doute lu notre tribune parue dans
libération qui précisément exprime avec
des membres du groupe socialiste et
apparentés des membres du groupe
écologie et démocratie des membres du
groupe de la france insoumise et du
groupe gdr qui signent et libertés
territoire j'en oublie et peut-être
d'autres qui voudraient signer je ne
veut oublier personne mais c'est juste
pour vous dire que dans de nombreux
groupes de notre assemblée la question
des ouigours tout ce qu'il ya sous forme
de groupe enfin tout ce qu'ils voient
nous sommes extrêmement nombreux ce à
travers les différentes sensibilités
politiques et que nous sommes
littéralement à l'armée non seulement à
l'égard de ces camps qui existent en
chine et de toutes ces pratiques de
torture des pratiques qui sont également
de stérilisation et avortement de masse
de travail forcé enfin je vais pas faire
la liste mais c'est d'une violence
inouïe alors vous nous dites juste
sondés violence injustifiable mais je
pense qu'on peut aller bien plus loin à
la fois dans la dénonciation est aussi
peut-être dans les moyens que nous avons
à mettre en oeuvre pour que notre parole
se fassent entendre
et il me semble que sur ce sujet nous
n'entendons pas la parole de la france
et je terminerai en disant que nous
l'avons en revanche particulièrement
entendu sur le liban et en des termes
venant du président de la république on
a l'impression que le liban est sous
protectorat français que la façon dont
le président l'a à la république c
ce prime vis-à-vis de cette situation
des dirigeants et du peuple libanais est
une ingérence inacceptable donc d'un
certain côté nous avons une ingérence
inacceptable et de l'autre côté pour les
ouigours nous avons un silence coupable
de la france et j'aimerais vraiment
solennellement je vous demande d'avoir
une position claire de qualifier ce qui
s'y passe de dire ce que nous pouvons
faire vis-à-vis d'entreprises françaises
qui par leurs activités sur place
de fait se trouve complices de ce qui
s'y passe que pouvons-nous faire je ne
pourrais accepter l'idée que notre
parole ne soit pas forte et que nous ne
puissions rien faire
merci chers collègues pour la gauche
démocrate et républicaine jean paul
lecoq
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
liste est longue mais j'ai retenu de
votre vos propos des phrases clés la
politique du fait accompli ne pourra
plus être la politique française et et
vous reviendrez au droit international
c'est intéressant et puis la fermeté
française dans sa justesse alors j'ai
commencé sur un premier sujet qui
concerne la france historiquement c'est
le sujet du soutien au président
comorien azali assoumani plutôt qu'à son
peuple puisque en 2018 ce putschiste a
mis en place un vote sur une réforme
constitutionnelle dont les observateurs
internationaux notamment ceux issus de
l'union africaine ont reconnu que le
résultat était sorti d'un bourrage
d'urnes
la france qui n'aurait jamais dû
reconnaître ce résultat puisque c'est ce
qu'elle a comme attitude ailleurs donc
pourquoi pas ici doit maintenant
demander je pense à l'exécutif de
reprendre les présidences tournantes et
et de remettre en place des élections en
novembre comme proposé dans la
constitution issue la réconciliation
nationale en deux en 2001 c'est
peut-être gage de paix d'agir ainsi et
de faire respecter les les accords
notamment signé sous l'égide de la
france
dans un second temps je pense que la
france devrait aussi
avoir un avis sur la candidature de
monsieur ouattara pour un troisième
mandat qui là encore est encontre ide en
contradiction avec la constitution
ivoirienne et avec les ses propres aux
engagements engagement d'ailleurs salué
par le président macro et d'autre part
est ce que la france compte s'exprimer
concernant la répression qui s'abat
actuellement sur les démocrates
ivoiriens je reviendrai pas sur la
question du mali parce que vous avez
beaucoup développée quatrièmement sur
donc troisièmement sur la après la
parution du rapport du secrétaire
général de l'onu sur le sahara
occidental une question fondamentale se
pose quel rôle joue la france dans
l'apps sa peau ce sujet que vos pots
sujets que j'aborde la question du
sahara occidental ici c'est bah merci
ben je sais pas je vous entend réagir
sur 7 sur ce sujet là donc sur la
question de savoir ce que c'est parce
que monsieur le ministre a abordé la
question que posait sa caisse politique
française ne s'appuierait plus sur le
fait accompli et donc je suis satisfait
de cette réaction et il a mis en avant
le retour au droit international le
propos comme c'est enregistré ici vous
pourrez le réécouter est donc dans le
code du retour au droit international la
question du sahara occidental est donc
posée et comme elle est posée il n'y a
pas actuellement de commissaire de l'onu
sûr
sur ce territoire et donc monsieur le
ministre avez vous agi auprès de l'onu
pour que à nouveau un commissaire et
lieu ensuite
un an après le grand dialogue national
au cameroun on observe que les fractures
au sein de la société sont toujours les
mêmes
la france soutient le président paul
biya depuis toujours mais il semblerait
que ce que ce ne soit plus possible donc
que compte faire la diplomatie pour
sortir de ce soutien qui n'est plus
acceptable et et pour terminer ce que la
diplomatie française compte réagir face
à l'offensive saoudienne et israéliennes
de réconciliation qui se fera sur le dos
de la palestine la france ne
pourrait-elle pas se rallier enfin aux
peuples opprimés pour faire avancer la
cause de la paix dans le monde puisque
c'est de cela qu'il s'agit quand on
discute avec le ministre des affaires
étrangères merci beaucoup chers
collègues pour le groupe liberté
territoire frédéric dumas merci monsieur
le président depuis le mois d'août la
chine effectué des incursions répétées
d'avions militaires militaire au delà de
la ligne médiane du détroit de taiwan
dont la partie sud ouest de la zone
d'identification de défense aérienne
tout en démentant l'existence de cette
ligne médiane pourtant une délimitation
tacitement respecté pendant des
décennies par chacune des rives du
détroit et qui est considéré par le
gouvernement taïwanais comme un élément
de statu quo selon le journal communiste
chinois global times ces opérations
doivent préparer l'armée populaire de
libération une possible future attaque
surtout à l approche de la période de
transfert de pouvoir s'il a lieu aux
états unis allié principal de taiwan
pendant laquelle taiwan s'avère plus
fragiles
les taiwanais sont donc dans une
situation plus que préoccupante dont
l'issue pourrait être d'une extrême
gravité
face aux rays chinois voulue par jean
ping qui consiste à unifier la chine et
ce par la force s'il le faut sébastien
beck directeur d'études à l'école des
hautes études en sciences sociales
affirme que pékin ne semble pas avoir
arrêté sa stratégie définitive par
rapport à taiwan et donc qu'il existe
encore une fenêtre pour mettre en place
une dissuasion international plus
efficace à condition que les pays
européens en est la volonté
monsieur le ministre quelles mesures
allez vous mettre en place pour
contribuer concrètement à l'aide
suivant international et éloigner les
menaces qui pèsent sur taïwan puisque
nous avons plutôt tendance à réagir
quand les choses se passent plutôt que
de les prévenir
sachant que par ailleurs lors du forum
de l'union européenne sur les
investissements 2020 la présidence de
taiwan madame sayin guen rappelé la
volonté de taiwan de négocier avec
l'union européenne un accord sur les
investissements en particulier sur les
secteurs des technologies de
l'information et de la communication des
bio techniques de la santé de la
mobilité
la france encourage ratel cette
proposition au sein des instances de
l'union européenne sachant que la
commissaire européenne magra marié
gabriel que nous avons auditionné la
semaine dernière s'est montrée ouverte à
une association avec taiwan si cela lui
était demandé officiellement
enfin monsieur mini jeux vous avez posé
une question lors de notre dernière
audition concernant l'éventuel
financement indirect de dèche par la
société française de rugby qui dispose
d'infrastructures de stockage et de
distribution de produits pétroliers sur
le port de ces en turquie où m'aviez
répondu je suis ouvert à tout examen du
dossier que vous évoquez je n'ai pas
d'information particulière alors que
vous semblez en avoir beaucoup je vous
remercie donc de m'en faire part que je
souhaite que toute la lumière soit faite
je vous ai envoyés dès le lendemain les
éléments que j'avais à ma disposition je
n'ai eu à ce jour aucun retour je pense
que nous pouvons toujours donner des
leçons à l'international et gonfler nos
muscles notamment avec la turquie mais
que la priorité c'est d'aller voir de
près ce que font nos emplois nos
entreprises nous avons failli passer à
côté de la fin je ne passons pas à côté
de ruby d'où l'importance du sujet que
représente la lutte contre le terrorisme
je pense que l'absence de réponse est
très préjudiciable
d'ailleurs j'avais également posé la
question à votre collègue christophe
castanet en question écrite je n'ai
toujours pas de réponse
enfin quant à la situation des ouigours
mais pas seulement oui mais je suis
désolé il ya une continuité de l'état
j'imagine j'espère en tout cas les deux
mois était passé quand c'était lui qui
était ministre
mais passe donc quant à l'institution
des ouigours et pas seulement car il
s'agit de l'ensemble des prisonniers de
conscience en chine
je m'associe à mes collègues j'ai aussi
déposé une proposition de loi concernant
les prélèvements non éthique d'organes
co signée par 64 de mes collègues de
toutes les sensibilités politiques
politiques confondues c'est un moyen
concret de dispositions d'encadrer les
coopérations scientifiques qui ont lieu
entre les établissements de
scientifiques et de santé français et
les établissements chinois
je n'ai pas de réponse aux filles
juste à nos chers collègues dans la
république non j'aimerais savoir si le
gouvernement donnera un avis favorable à
cette proposition de loi qui est un
outil concret ma chère merci beaucoup
pour écologie démocratie solidarité
hubert julien laferrière merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre le 15
septembre dernier à la maison blanche
sous la présidence de donald trump
les émirats arabes unis le bahreïn ont
signé des accords de normalisation avec
israël
les accords d'abraham évidemment quand
la paix progresse quand la
reconnaissance d'israël qui assure
rester une démocratie alors qu'elle
était entourée d'état qui souhaitait sa
disparition et bien quand cette
reconnaissance progresse à priori il
faut s'en réjouir
néanmoins vous le savez avec 60
parlementaires
nous avons interrogé par une tribune
dont est à l'initiative sur les angles
morts nous sommes interrogés sur les
angles morts de ces accords dont nous
craignons qu'il ne soit pas forcément
propice à favoriser une paix juste
outre que l'on ne peut ignorer ce qui se
joue pour la riche fédération des
émirats arabes unis qui fut à la tête
des forces qui souhaitent et clore
l'épisode des printemps arabes qui usent
autant de de soft power que que doit
pouvoir pour faire avancer ses intérêts
dans la région au yémen où nous sommes
témoins impuissants d'une catastrophe
humanitaire en libye
elle n'est pas la seule mais où son
ingérence et est dénoncée par les
organisations des droits humains
nous sommes effectivement interrogé par
ce que nous avons à faire un raccord
d'abord qui ne change rien pour les
palestiniens leurs droits fondamentaux
ne sont pas prises en compte
ces accords ne change rien au régime
d'occupation on a même vu que la
colonisation continue depuis la
signature des accords avec netanyahu a
approuvé la construction de 5000
nouveaux logements en cisjordanie et
pire le projet d'annexion dénoncé par la
france d'une grande partie de la
cisjordanie n'est même pas abandonner
dans le cadre de ces accords
contrairement à ce qu'affirme et
désirable les émirats arabes unis et
puis nous nous sommes interrogés sur un
accord qui rompt avec le consensus arabe
tel qu'édicté en 2002 par le plan du roi
saoudien abdallah un consensus qui est
une vraie feuille de route qui prévoyait
une paix globale entre israël et tous
ses voisins arabes en échange de la
création d'un état palestinien sur les
frontières de 67 avec jérusalem est
comme capitale
évidemment la solution que la france
soutient et fils est officiellement donc
avec cet accord les émirats en fait en
font voler en éclats ce consensus et et
brisé un double paradigme celui de voir
le conflit israélo arabe se clore selon
un schéma multi multilatérale et la
nécessité de revenir au droit
international comme base de règlement
des conflits
aussi monsieur mise pouvez vous nous
rappeler dans ce contexte qu'elle est là
la position de la france sur ces accords
et sur ce qu'ils signifient pour
l'avenir de notre diplomatie dans la
région pour l'avenir de notre soutien à
une paix juste qui n'oublie aucun peuple
je vous remercie
merci beaucoup chers collègues
voilà une première série de questions
monsieur le ministre nous voilà
désormais heures de groupe et surtout
nous avons
nous aurons c'est de beaucoup de
collègues qui vont prendre la parole
mais nous allons nous avons donné la
parole par 12 de manière à courcy ce
serait plus facile pour moi parce que je
vais devoir partir à 17h30
étant donné la situation internationale
j'ai pas mal de rendez vous téléphonique
donc je peux pas aller au delà de 17
heures pendant si j'ai pas fini je
finirai la semaine prochaine parce que
là je pourrai pas mais ça fait 2 ça fera
deux heures et demie se trouve que c'est
déjà un moment important sur place des
sujets importants
je vais essayer de répondre à tous là
j'espère que ne pas oublier voilà alors
sur le haut-karabagh il ya en fait il y
avait deux questions toutefois deux
ensemble de questions qui étaient de
madame clapot et de monsieur tessier
pour être très clair surtout avec
l'observation monsieur testé qu'ils sont
de 2 la plus politiquement la plus
interrogatifs j'ai revenir sur ce que
disait madame plein pot sur leur
particulier le
le rôle des ong sur les les combats qui
tuent les civils mais moi je ne suis pas
sur la ligne
on peut avoir ce désaccord de renoncer à
notre rôle dans le cadre du processus de
minsk
j'ai lu les tribunes qui disent il faut
que la france sorte d'une forme
d'impartialité que lui confère
obligatoirement sa forme sa position du
groupe de minsk
je pense que ce n'est pas on a chacun
sait une relation historique amicales
fraternelles avec des arméniens et je ne
suis pas sûr que ce soit rendre service
aux arméniens que de le faire d'ailleurs
ils ne nous demandent pas ils ne nous
demandent pas non j'ai mon collègue
arménien à tous les jours au téléphone
je le connais très bien et il ne demande
pas ça ils ne demandent que la france
joue son rôle que les autorités
arméniennes me suis passionné aimant
collègue denise affaires étrangères ne
demande que la france joue son rôle
auprès de la russie et auprès d'eux des
états unis pour provoquer à la fois le
cessez le feu est aussi le processus de
négociations la faute que nous avons
collectivement tous les 3es et aussi
finalement les états unis les arméniens
et les azerbaïdjanais c'est que de ne
pas avoir engagé sérieusement la
négociation sur les territoires et je
comprends que certains disent oui bah on
va faire le cessez le feu puis on va en
rester là il y aura une ligne de
démarcation mais on veut repartir pour
dix ans donc il faut que soient tous
assuré qu' il ya le cessez le feu il ya
l'engagement immédiat de discussion sur
le territoire parce qu'il n'ya pas que
le territoire vous le savez très bien
madame que la poésie même que le
territoire identifié sur la carte
centrale on va passer de cartes là mais
de dieu aux caravanes il ya aussi les
districts avoisinants qui font l'objet
de combats et donc posons ça sur la
table et commençons commençons la
négociation sur les bases d'un
cessez-le-feu tel qu'il est là
aujourd'hui
en demandant la non intervention de
puissances extérieures
là je réponds même que la peau et je
pense à partir de la turquie nous avons
désigné nature qui en estimant qu' il
fallait que l'intervention de la turquie
sur sur la zone les zones en question
sait c'est que les livraisons d'armes
cesse et en particulier que les
mercenaires syrien transférer puisque
manninen maintenant on a quasiment les
preuves soient rapatriés là où deux qui
viennent là où tu d'où lui viennent donc
voilà sur ce point nous avons peut-être
un désaccord mais c'est pense que le
meilleur rôle que nous devons jouer
c'est celui-là sur madame plateau
concernant les jeux retrouve plus
mineures
vos observations sur l'est les civils
c'est vrai que les conflits continuent
c'est vrai que des bombardements se
poursuivaient en particulier dans la
ville principale de stepanakert c'est
des bombardements au lieu ça entraîne
des des migrations des situations très
difficiles nous nous redisons qu' il ya
les lois de la guerre nate est interdit
de frapper les civils des ondes aux deux
parties parce qu'il a de la gare se
déclenchent les deux parties agissent et
nous souhaitons qu'ils puissent aboutir
à une solution qui évite de l'agression
contre les civils et nous participons
aussi à l'intervention des ong pour
aider les populations du haut karabagh
dans l'un des faits dans leurs
difficultés mais il faut arrêter
l'escaladé
c'est pour nous une exigence et c'est le
rôle diplomatique que de le faire savoir
de faire pression sur les uns et sur les
autres pour qu'ils puissent aboutir à
une solution de début de négociation
n'aboutira pas une fan négociations tout
de suite et on s'est trop compliqué et
je souhaite donc que les hypothèses de
négociations qui sont en cours
aujourd'hui puissent aboutir à une vraie
une vraie discussion tout en comprenant
la l'empathie qui a été évoqué par
madame la peau est pas monsieur d'ici à
l'égard des des arméniens pour ça
monsieur changé et je répondrai aussi
indirectement à monsieur habile sur le
liban près je reviendrai sur le la rue
des rosiers
je ne pense pas qu'il faille commencer
par une réforme de la constitution
je le dis comme ces publics je fais très
attention à ce que je dis mais je pense
que le pire serait une fuite en avant
dans le temps
sans doute faut-il y penser mais
l'urgence au liban c'est une feuille de
route gouvernementale d'action sinon on
réformera une constitution sur un pays
disloqué et qu' une constitution qui ne
servirait pas qui ne serait rien c'est à
dire le même le même sujet sur des
élections anticipées est ce qu'il faut
faire
vu la crise et ce qu'il faut faire des
élections anticipées si on fait des
élections anticipées on va reposer le
problème constitutionnel
et on va rediscuter pendant un an un an
et demi
et pendant ce temps là le pays va
sombrer le pays est en train de sombrer
et donc moi je n'ai pas d'opposition sur
la réflexion constitutionnelle du liban
ça ça posera un moment donné parce qu'on
voit bien que le dispositif aujourd'hui
n'est plus pertinent mais pense que
l'urgence c'est que les les différentes
parties du liban se met en mouvement
pour faire en sorte qu' un gouvernement
d'action qui ceux qui se constituent sur
le sur le saint siège
moi je me suis entretenu à rome
le cardinal a role in à plusieurs
reprises de la situation du liban au
liban ils ont un peu va voir un rôle d'
influence non négligeable comme
d'ailleurs le patriarche maronite de
monseigneur rails karine monseigneur
rails avec qui je m'entretiens à chaque
à chaque visite au liban ils ont un rôle
de pression ils ont un rôle d' influence
qu'il est tout à fait essentiel utilisé
dans cette période où je pense que c'est
il faut que les acteurs libanais
comprennent que la population n'attend
que cela souhaite cela et qu'ils ne sont
peut-être plus en phase
de même avec les populations qui les
soutiennent du coup du coup monsieur
habib sur la partie s bolam je vais
redire ce que je vous savez un il se
trouve que il y à des libanais qui
votent pour le vc vaulx la politique
c'est comme ça et donc on est bien
obligé de tenir compte des votes des uns
et des autres bon si les personnes qui
votaient pour le hezbollah c'est une
organisation qui n'est pas
représentative mais il y a des 8 bat
n'est qu'ils votent pour le hesbollah
nombre significatif donc ils
représentent quelque chose d'une force
politique nous sommes nous condamnons la
force militaire mais nous sommes dans le
la discussion avec le hezbollah qui doit
pas il doit être partie prenante de
l'ensemble du dispositif
d'ailleurs il a il a été et puis savez
au liban je vois ici non celle des
députés qui connaissent bien le liban
tout le monde parle avec tout le monde
et tout le monde raconte avec tout le
monde et tout le monde se parle
leur problème c'est que ça fait pas une
solution mais mais mais tout le monde se
parle compris
responsable du hezbollah la condamnation
que nous avons c'est sur le hesbollah
militaires que nous condamnons et sur
lesquels nous avons une position très
rigoureux je profite d'ailleurs pour
répondre à monsieur a vu que sur l'
enquête sur l'explosion du port n'est
pas achevée alors vous avez sans doute
des informations particulières moi je ne
les ai pas il ya une enquête à laquelle
la france participe puisque nous
apportons nos deux des contributions en
personne en expert pour la bon résultat
de cette de cette enquête
je reviens wrestler dans le nombre de
passages sur sur la rue des rosiers sur
taïwan monsieur david nous sommes
favorables à ce que taiwan participe aux
travaux le ms je l' ai déjà dit à
plusieurs reprises parce que nous
estimons que pour avoir une gestion
efficace de la pandémie des pandémies
d'une manière générale ça suppose la
participation de tous aux travaux le m s
jeudi à plusieurs reprises mais madame
dumas
nous ne reconnaissons qu'une seule chine
depuis c'est vous qui m'avez posé la
question sur taïwan il y a une seule
chine
non c'est parce qu'ils qu'est-ce qui
m'interrogeait sur taïwan monsieur david
et vous même tout à leur nom
vous m'avez parlé de taiwan sur la
liberté de navigation il me semble ou
alors j'entends des voix
non mais même à ma réponse à cela je
vous le dis là puisque je parlais mais
ce que je réponds à monsieur david oui
pour que taiwan participe à l'om est
parce qu il faut que tous les
territoires participent à l'éradication
des idées des pandémies et nous l'avons
dit chacun le sait mais sur taïwan
il y a une seule chine et ne reverront
pas sur ses fondamentaux qui sont
d'ailleurs les fondamentaux de la france
depuis le général de gaulle mais puisque
j'y suis madame dumas
je fais un peu de patchwork dans les
questions mais puisque puisque j'y suis
sale ça ne ça ne m'empêche pas que nous
sommes très vigoureusement pour la
liberté de navigation dans les eaux au
delà des eaux territoriales des
différents pays et que nous sommes
proposés à la comment dire l'espèce de
prééminence que la chine veut exercer en
rupture avec le droit international de
la mer
sur l'ensemble de la mer de chine
méridionale et ça nous l'avons marqué à
plusieurs reprises très fortement je le
redis ici ça vaut pour eux aussi pour
comment s'appellent les neuf îles donc
je crois que c'est l'un des films les
deux retraits la théorie des neuf près
les 9,9 archipel willot qui sont le long
de la mer de chine et que la chine veut
considérer entre le territoire
continental et saisi lé comme une mer
intérieure somme proposée à ça voilà et
est sûr mais je profite pour terminer
pour votre réponse madame dumas sur
rubis nous avons j'ai pris bonne note de
ce que vous nous avez dit nous
poursuivons nos investigations par des
moyens appropriés
donc sur monsieur guerrab sur le franc
cfa
nous n'avons pas à nous substituer aux
acteurs de ce nouveau dispositif
monétaire ce qui ce qui est certain
c'est que à l'occasion de la visite du
président de la république en côte
d'ivoire en décembre dernier la france
et l'union économique et monétaire des
états d'afrique de l'ouest lui et noah
ont signé un nouvel accord de
coopération militaire qui suppose le
changement non seulement le changement
de nom de la monnaie des etats unis
durement acquis prix a priori
deviendrait l'écho mais le le nom de la
future monnaie ne fait pas encore
consensus qui signifie aussi la fin de
la centralisation des réserves de
changes de la banque centrale des états
l'a fait de wes auprès du trésor
français qui signifie aussi le retrait
de la france des instances de
gouvernance dans lesquels ils étaient
présents donc si on se retire de nos
instances de gouvernance c'est pas moi
qui vais vous dire monsieur guerrab
aujourd'hui voilà ce qu'ils vont faire
pour constituer le l'écho ou un nom de
monnaie qui correspond à la nouvelle
donne qui est donné mais le projet de
loi d'approbation de l'accord a été
présenté au conseil des ministres au
mois de mai et le texte est actuellement
en cours d'examen à l'assemblée
nationale je crois que le rapporteur
c'est monsieur jean françois bay qui est
membre de cette commission
donc nous souhaitons que ça aille au
bout et que la circulation de cette
nouvelle monnaie soit réalisée dès que
les autorités de ces pays
le jugeront utiles c'est un acte très
important très significative très plus
que symbolique qui marque là une
nouvelle donne dans l'afrique de l'ouest
sur
non je crois que c'était tout votre
question c'est dans ce surnom sur les
battre sur les bateaux moi je nous
essayons de faire en sorte que les le
retour de nos compatriotes au du maroc
avait des copies car soit facilité on a
mis en place des bateaux mais
nous sommes disposés à agir en
complément c'était un problème très
difficile les camping cars parce qu'en
plus à des mesures marocaine à ces sur
l'algérie je vais regarder celle pas je
me rende en algérie prochainement donc
je ferai je ferai le point small avec
les autorités à john je n'avais pas
j'avais j'avais les camping-cars du
maroc mais j'avais pas le camping cars à
john alors monsieur habib sur la rue des
rosiers
en complément nous avons toujours
demandé l'extradition des personnes
responsables de l'attentât j'en ai parlé
à plusieurs reprises s'il m'entend
monsieur à ma collègue norvégienne et
finalement les différentes démarches que
nous avons pu entreprendre abouti à
l'extradition de monsieur walid abu
rahma abou zayed
c'est une première étape vers un procès
et je n'oublie pas qu'il y à d'autres
personnes susceptibles d'être extradé et
j'en parle régulièrement avec les
intéressés jordanien en particulier
madame madame autun bon vous pouvez
porter un jugement très négatif sur les
déclarations c'est votre droit
j'observe simplement concernant les
ouigours je vais pas vous redire ce que
j'ai dit hier je vais pas redire ce que
j'ai dit deux fois au mois de juillet
peut-être que vous n'avez pas entendu
mais j'ai dit j'ai parlé donc trois fois
l'assemblée nationale sur les huit jours
donc je ne suis pas silencieux ou alors
je ne comprends plus moi même si comme
je parle personne ne l'entend ça devient
un problème
j'ai aussi parlé au sénat sur les mêmes
sujets et j'ai une position extrêmement
claire
c'est donc ce n'est pas le silence je
n'accepte pas ce procès d'intention
c'est le refus de la situation dans
laquelle les autorités chinoises mettent
aujourd'hui les ouigours vous avez
raison de parler de tout cela je les ai
évoqué à plusieurs reprises
je pourrais vous en voyez peut-être
qu'on fasse à les copies de journal
officiel et donc je le faire parce que
le mois de juillet c'est au jo donc
puisque vous n'avez pas entendu vous
pourrez me lire et et je dis et je dis
merci et donc sur sur ce sujet il ya une
urgence et si vous pouviez appuyer cette
démarche c'est que l' autre représentant
des droits de l'homme madame bachelet
des nations unies dont sont membres les
dons ont été membres la chine puisse
faire une mission d'inspection donc tout
transportant avec des experts nécessaire
en toute transparence pour vérifier
montrer à l'opinion publique
internationale ce qui se passe là elle
est d'accord pour y aller j'ai fait
cette démarche auprès d'elle et voilà
une action très concrètes
la chine peut difficilement refuser donc
qu'on pousse les autorités chinoises à
accepter que ça se passe dans la plus
grande transparence et sur la question
des entreprises que vous n'avez pas tout
entendu main ma réponse hier je me suis
très tout à fait clairement exprimé sur
le sujet et sur le respect de la loi du
27 mars
2017 pour les entreprises y compris les
sociétés mères dans le respect des
droits de l'homme par rapport à leur
chaîne d'approvisionnement
c'est dans le texte de ma réponse hier
voilà sur cela le protect le l'ingérence
française au liban je m'en suis exprimé
qu'est ce qu'on aurait dit si le
président de la république n'était pas
allé après l'explosion
cessons de ce que vous vouliez il la
pensée que le valais fait mieux faire le
contraire est présent au liban après ce
drame
qu'est ce qu'on aurait dit si le
président de république n'était pas allé
marquer le centenaire de la création du
liban le 1er septembre il se trouve que
ça tombait au moment d'une crise
politique et ça lui a permis de
rencontrer les différents responsables
politiques libanais qu'est ce qu'on
aurait dit si n'était pas monsieur le
coq pour les comores je ne sais pas de
vous intéresser aux comores mais c'est
un sujet un porte à 6 mayotte oui je
sais plus et plus c'était à c'était il
ya longtemps mais bon le comores ont
fait leur choix et moi nous avons pris
acte de la deûle à ce qui s'est passé
électoralement aux comores et nous
n'avons pas le lien est venu à ce côté 1
présidentielle en 2018
nous avons pris acte de ce résultat et
nous avons engagé un renouvellement de
notre relation avec des comores qui
aboutit à un accord que j'ai signé ici
le 22 juillet 2019 qui permet de donner
un nouvel élan notre coopération qui
permet en particulier des engagements
réciproques en matière d aide au
développement et de maîtrise des flux
2010 migration irrégulière et donc nous
sommes dans cette discussion là en ce
moment avec un mobilisation financière
assez significatif pour pour les comores
y compris dans le plan de riposte
lié à la pandémie dans cet archipel
je connais la situation peut-être moins
que moi bien que vous n'êtes compliqué d
des comores avec les engagements qui ont
été pris de part le président allait
mais il n'empêche que nous devons
marquer notre solidarité avec cet
archipel et j'ai suivre moi pour ma part
très attaché ainsi sur le la riposte
comorienne par rapport à l'aco vidéo 19
nous avons mobilisé déjà un million et
demi pour aider les comores à faire face
à cette situation sur le sahara
occidental je suis d'accord avec vous il
est urgent qui dit un remplacement au
l'ancien l'ancien président allemand
cole qui a dû arrêter pour des raisons
de santé
et donc c'est important qui ait pas trop
de vide et nous avons fait savoir
savourer au secrétaire général des
nations unies pour avoir le avoir le
relais sur la côte d'ivoire nous sommes
très très vigilants sur la manière dont
vont se passer les élections
je ne crois pas qu'on est
automatiquement à ceux à ce second bios
russie d'allier des dizaines de milliers
de personnes qui manifestent dans les
rues
je ne peux pas je suis désolé je fait
pas des comparaisons hâtives
ce qu'il y a il se trouve qu'il ya un
processus démocratique en côte d'ivoire
même s'il peut y avoir une discussion
sur la nouvelle constitution
mais moi je ne suis pas chargé
d'apprécier la nouvelle constitution de
de côte d'ivoire
ce serait là vraiment de l'ingérence en
l'occurrence donc je souhaite simplement
que et vous savez très bien monsieur le
kop pourquoi nous en sommes là en raison
du décès de monsieur du premier ministre
coulibaly coulibaly qui du fait de ce
seul fait très très proche des élections
présidentielle qui vont avoir lieu très
très bientôt le 31 octobre prochain
le président ouattara a estimé devoir
sur prêts se représenter c'est son libre
choix nous sommes nous souffle notre
souci c'est de faire en sorte que les le
déroulé de ces élections se déroulent
dans la partialité et dans un climat
apaisé en tout cas c'est le mandat que
nous donnons à nos collaborateurs et à
nos représentants sur place
voilà sur le divan j'avais besoin de
plus tu as de sueur de la même manière
sur sur le cameroun
je m'étais engagé à me rendre au
cameroun à partir du moment où d acte
d'apaisement étaient mises en place par
le président dia c'était en octobre 2019
et développé avec lui même et son
gouvernement à ce moment là on tient une
discussion assez franches en particulier
sur la nécessité de mettre en place une
décentralisation qui aboutissent à ce
que la crise du nord-ouest et du
sud-ouest du cameroun puisse
aboutir à une apaisement de la situation
et nous nous appelons la suite du décès
en détention de journalistes wazi les
autorités camerounaises à mener une
enquête indépendante et impartiale sur
les circonstances de sa mort et nous
invitons les autorités camerounaises à
prendre les initiatives les gestes
d'ouverture nécessaires pour rétablir la
confiance sur la scène de la politique
intérieure n'avons jamais été dans
toujours tenu ce discours y compris sur
place lorsque je me suis rendu l'intérêt
des camerounais c'est de favoriser le
dialogue entre les différentes parties
prenantes des différentes élections
régionales en vue d'un qui vont avoir
lieu au mois de décembre en vue d'un
scrutin transparent et dans un climat
politique apaisé c'est la même logique
que nous développons hors côte d'ivoire
monsieur julien laferrière sûr du coup
c'est aussi une partie de réponse à
monsieur le coq sur l'accord entre les
émirats arabes unis et israël les
chaussons sont très claires pour nous
nous avons salué ces accords parce qu'il
contribue à la stabilité et à la paix
mais nous avons dit en même temps que la
suspension des annexions devaient
devenir définitives et que le
contexte nouveau créé par ces accords
devraient permettre la relance d'une
négociation pour la solution à deux
états nous l'avons dit publiquement
plusieurs fois c'est très clair et et
dense est dans cette direction nous dans
cette perspective nous avons pris
contact avec l'allemagne la jordanie et
l'egypte pour engager un processus qui
pourrait aller dans ce sens je me suis
rendu d'ailleurs à cet égard à amman
pour cette rencontre qui a été publique
et nous avons fait une conférence de
presse publique nous ne cachons pas sur
nos positions mais vous n'êtes pas sans
savoir monsieur jean allaire qui lie à
un événement qu'il fasse passer
prochainement de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique et qui aujourd'hui bloc
beaucoup de discussions potentiel qui
pourrait se développer sur ce sujet
comme sur d'autres la tente du scrutin
du 4 novembre météo même un sujet majeur
de la politique internationale profonde
merci monsieur le ministre nous allons
donc passer aux questions des collègues
isabelle roche en tant que vice
présidente qui est à présider l'audition
de madame stridents des tic anoska ya ce
matin je donne donc la parole pour poser
la première question
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
en effet je souhaitais revenir sur
l'audition de ce matin deux villes
canadiennes de ce que ja et je
souhaitais d'ailleurs remercié la
présidente marielle de sarnez de m'avoir
fait confiance pour présider cette
audition ça a été un moment très fort
pour notre commission et nous avons vu
où nous avons entendu quelqu'un de
déterminé avec une voix posée
plein de courage et qui incarne vraiment
la voix de son peuple
effectivement je vous confirme que
devant notre commission elle a bien tenu
les mêmes propos qu'elle vous avez tenu
elle vit à vilnius ans donc elle a
remercié la france pour son soutien elle
remercie le président de la république
emmanuel macron pour tout ce qu'il peut
faire et pour notamment les le fait de
ne pas reconnaître le vote du 9 août
donc vraiment elle et elle nous
encourage et nous a demandé aussi de
continuer à la soutenir
elle nous a bien repréciser que son
peuple était uni puisque elle nous a
indiqué aussi que maintenant même les
personnes âgées étaient descendus dans
la rue et manifester
donc elle prôné vous nous l'avez rappelé
vous l'avez dit des élections libres et
non truquées pour un pays libre libre de
se dé de se déterminer de se choisir
librement
donc effectivement elle nous a bien
parlé des axes stratégiques avec la
pression intérieure par tout ce qui est
manifestations et la pression extérieure
donc les sanctions et tout ce que l'on
peut mettre en place et elle nous a à
cette occasion fait des demandes
concrètes la création d'un couloir
humanitaire pour les victimes de
violences notamment en raison de leur
engagement politique
l'accueil des étudiants biélorusse ans à
l'heure actuelle nous n'avons que quatre
bourses de disponible donc ça c'est une
demande qu'elle nous a qu'elle nous a
vraiment demain fête et puis aussi par
rapport à la pression extérieure de
relayer de diffuser le travail des
journalistes indépendants de faire en
sorte que l'on parle de façon le plus
possible positivement de la biélorussie
et de l'unité de son peuple et de la
volonté de se déterminer librement
et puis enfin nous a fait une dernière
demande qui est plutôt en forme
d'invitation une invitation à venir en
biélorussie voir comment ça se passe
voir la façon dont son peuple est uni et
quand nous a fait cette demande sur mon
téléphone j'ai reçu énormément de
messages à ce moment là des collègues
parlementaires qui effectivement trouvé
que c'était une très bonne idée et qui
ont vraiment envie de faire en sorte que
cette délégation puisse se faire voilà
j'ai un tout petit peu dépassé mais il
me semble est quand même très important
de pouvoir revenir sur cette audition
qui était un moment très fort et très
important pour la vie de notre
commission je vous remercie
merci chers collègues sur isabelle je
vais donner la parole jean françois
bailly merci monsieur le président je le
ministre le 9 août dernier dans une
autre partie est dans une autre zone du
monde ont été sauvagement assassinés six
ressortissants français d'omg au sud
ouest du niger les je veux ici saluer la
mémoire de ces personnels humanitaires
qui sont souvent envoyés dans des zones
de crise très difficile
là où les états ne vont plus la
protection de ses personnels
humanitaires en zone de conflit est une
question récurrente et les atteintes
sont de plus en plus importante et ça
nous inquiète
ça nous inquiète et c'est dans ce sens
que mon collègue monteil brotherson et
moi-même nous nous sommes saisis de
cette question et y avions rendu très
récemment dans cette commission un
rapport sur la question sur le droit
international humanitaire
ma question monsieur le ministre c'est
aujourd'hui est ce que la diplomatie
française par votre voix serait disposé
à ouvrir rapidement très rapidement une
réflexion portant sur la création d'un
statut international du personnel
humanitaire c'est la proposition numéro
12 que nous avions faites dans ce dans
ce rapport cela fait écho aussi à vos
propos que vous aviez tenu en octobre
2017 puisque vous étiez sensible à cette
question là et puis dernière question le
cas échéant que pouvez vous nous dire
aujourd'hui sur l'aide qui est apportée
la coopération que la france met en
oeuvre avec l'état du niger pour mener à
bien les investigations de ces
personnels humanitaires qui ont été je
le rappelle sauvagement assassinée je
vous remercie
merci chers collègues à paroles est un
école trice oui merci monsieur le
ministre je voudrais vous parler du
haut-karabakh encore alors que la russie
s'était imposé comme l' arbitre du
différend territorial entre l'arménie et
l'azerbaïdjan il semblerait que le
kremlin est perdue des marges de
manoeuvre au profit de la turquie la
turquie a à plusieurs reprises déclaré
son soutien à l'azerbaïdjan
et il semblerait vous l'aviez dit tout à
l'heure que effectivement nous avons des
preuves que la turquie soutiennent
militairement les troupes
azerbaïdjanaise d'engager au haut
karabakh
même si cette présence est
n'est pas vraiment enfin et en tout cas
démenti par ankara et bakou
le président de la république emmanuel
macron a récemment demandé des
explications à la turquie sur son
implication dans le conflit avec
l'emploi de avec l'envoi de centaines de
jihadistes en tant que ministre des
affaires étrangères pouvez vous nous
donner votre point de vue sur ces
interventions militaires turcs et sur
les relations que vous entretenez avec
votre homologue turc merci merci chers
collègues je vais donner la parole à
notre collègue ramla si ali et ensuite à
michel herbillon
j'aime c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon
merci mais c'est le ministre comme vous
venez de le dire le 22 juillet 2019
vous avez signé à paris avec votre
homologue comorien un document cadre de
partenariat entre la france et les
comores présenté comme inaugurant une
nouvelle page entre les relations
diplomatiques de ces deux pays
depuis cette date comme l'indiqué ce
document le calendrier de suivi a été
ténue avec des réunions du comité de
suivi entre les deux parties pour y
participer
je sais et je salue les efforts
entrepris par l'état français sur ce
dossier toutefois des événements récents
appels flottement mon attention
un nouveau drame de l'immigration
clandestine a eu lieu avec la mort du
comorien dont un enfant dans le naufrage
d'un kwassa kwassa le 24 septembre 2020
semaine 24 décembre 2020 le président
comorien azali assoumani devant les
nations unies est intervenu en
réaffirmant la souveraineté de son pays
sur mayotte
celui-ci dit et je les cite la
souveraineté sur mayotte est un combat
légitime dans lequel tout comorien doit
se reconnaître et il a rappelé la
signature des accords cadres avec la
france en juillet 2010 heure 10 ans
commenté sur la volonté de chaque pays
pour trouver une
solution a sonné je cite encore
contentieux désagréable dans le plan de
développement france qu'au bord annexée
au document cadre une large place est
accordée à la sécurité des personnes et
à la nécessité d'un renforcement de
mayotte française dans son environnement
régional
or les déclarations du président
comorien nous laisse mon new marais
fortement perplexe quant à sa volonté de
respecter cet accord
à la lumière de ces faits mais sur le
ministre pouvez vous nous faire un état
actuel des relations diplomatiques entre
la france et l'union des comores
que compte faire l'état français pour
faire respecter l'accord france union
des comores merci merci chers collègues
à la suite la suite de michel herbillon
nous aurons amelia la graphie ensuite
didier contant oui merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre vous avez
évoqué de nombreuses crises et encore
comme vous l'avez dit vous n'avez pas
les que celle du mois d'août mais je
voudrais vous demander à à l'occasion de
ces différentes crises nous avons noté
qu'il y avait effectivement une parole
forte du président de la république ou
de vous même la diplomatie française en
même temps comme le comme vous dites
gouvernement et de la majorité
on peine parfois à voir les résultats
concrets de ses prises de position alors
je sais bien que la diplomatie les
négociations prennent du temps
moi je voudrais que vous nous disiez
devant notre commission quels sont les
sorties de crise que vous tels que vous
les envisagées telles que vous les
portez des différentes crises que vous
avez évoquées parce que c'est ça
finalement qui retient notre attention
bien entendu il ya des prises de paroles
fortes mais il ya le préau la public qui
a sur le liban notamment une part
extrêmement forte en disant qu'il avait
honte
et puis après c'est quoi la sortie de
crise c'est quoi la certains oui mais
c'est nous on est très attentif aussi à
cela comme vous l'êtes c'est quoi la
sortie de crise pour le haut karabakh
pendant ce temps tous les jours il ya
des civils et de nombreux civils qui
meurent c'est quoi la sortie de crise
vis de la russie à propos de la faire
nos valises c'est quoi la sortie de
crise concernant la biélorusse la
biélorussie parce que on a fait cette
audition tout à fait intéressant que ce
matin mais ensuite parce que quand on
quelle est l'action de la france je sais
vous connaissant bien que vous êtes
attachés à des résultats concrets et pas
simplement à des déclarations et des
incantations et donc je souhaiterais que
vous éclairer notre commission sur les
résultats concrets tels que vous les
entrevoyez de ces différentes crises et
la première question est la seconde je
suis toujours dans les temps je voudrais
que vous nous disiez de manière un petit
peu génériques
comment vous percevez en tant que
ministre des affaires étrangères le rôle
de la turquie
et est ce que ce rôle ne vous préoccupe
pas et là aussi parce que je pense que
ce le rôle de la turquie est vraiment
préoccupant sur les différentes et
comment vous envisagez le les
discussions avec la turquie qui me
paraît être un acteur on va dire je vais
dire ça comme ça compliqué d de la
géopolitique et notamment prochain
merci chers collègues
amelia de la graphie merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre c'est
toujours un plaisir de vous avoir dans
notre profession
alors concernant l'aide apportée par la
france au secteur privé en afrique et
notamment aux lèvres les entreprises
le français de l'étranger elle a un
moment été adoptées dans le cadre du
plfr vous m'entendez oui d'accord
donc je disais un amendement du
gouvernement a été adopté dans le plfr 3
en juillet dernier prévoyant l'octroi
d'une garantie de la fbi afin de
permettre à proparco d'accorder des
prêts et garanties à hauteur de 160
millions d'euros aux entreprises et
institutions financières secteur privé
africain
cette mesure soutenue par les idées et
pour laquelle je me suis
particulièrement mobilisés ainsi que ma
collègue agent et vise en particulier à
permettre aux tpe et m
en afrique dont celles qui ont été qui
sont détenus par des français installés
là-bas d'obtenir des financements auprès
des institutions bancaires
je comprends parfaitement qu'il soit
techniquement très difficile
mettre en place un tel dispositif qui
nécessite de définir des critères des
livres des gélules un de droit
d'éligibilité rigoureux toutefois si
j'en crois monsieur le secrétaire d'état
jean baptiste le moigne ce dispositif ne
sera mis en place
pas avant la fin de l'année soit plus de
six mois et malgré l'urgence extrême
après le vote de ce dispositif nous est
il possible noté le ministre de nous en
dire davantage sur le calendrier de mise
en place
récit de cet outil et s'il serait
possible d'étendre cet outil à d'autres
régions la rd n'étant pas contre ensuite
concernant la crise qui touche le liban
vous l'avez largement abordée l'impasse
politique sont aujourd'hui total tandis
que l'on près d'une grave crise
alimentaire qui pourrait toucher la
population
le président de la république c'est
tellement mobilisés pour la population
libanaise a récemment extrême exprimé sa
honte devant une trahison de la classe
politique je voudrais savoir est-ce que
selon vous le premier ministre désigné
mustapha a dit de retour en allemagne
qui a jeté l éponge pourrait reprendre
du service
est ce que le déplacement du président
maquereau en décembre at il confirmé
l'agenda de la france face à la
situation de blocage absolument extrême
pour les libanais et les bonne
mobilisation de la communauté
internationale
merci chers collègues après didier
quentin se prépare nicole le pea n a
cure et que laurence dumont nicolas
dupont aignan bruno fuchs
voilà merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre je vais vous poser
une question qui peut sembler un peu
périphériques mais qui a une certaine
importance en terme géopolitique cette
question elle vient après le deuxième
référendum qui s'est tenu ce dimanche 4
octobre sur la question de l'avenir de
la nouvelle calédonie il n'y a que dix
mille voix d'écart entre les loyalistes
et les indépendantistes et dans la
perspective où le troisième référendum
fortement envisagée aboutir à
l'indépendance de la nouvelle calédonie
est-ce que vous avez des remontées
d'informations notamment de la part de
l'australie de la nouvelle zélande peut
être d'autres puissances voisines sur
les éventuelles inquiétudes quant à une
présence plus affirmée de la chine dans
l'hypothèse de cette indépendance et
dans cet espace indo pacifique
je me souviens qu'il avait été question
dans une voie grande autorité
d'hégémonisme chinois merci cher
collègue nicole le p merci monsieur le
président monsieur minister sheikh
jean-yves je souhaite faire suite à
l'audition de ce matin à l'occasion de
laquelle le madame des canaux sky a
indiqué que les sanctions actuelles ne
doivent être que le début de la pression
exercée par les pays européens sur le
régime loukachenko ou sont d'après vous
les fragilités du régime et sur lesquels
ils pourraient très nécessaire d'appuyer
davantage
je vous remercie merci beaucoup cher
collègue laurence dumont je change
oui bonjour à tous
bonjour monsieur le ministre monsieur le
ministre dès votre prise de fonction en
2017 et en réaction à vos interventions
à l'onu sur la question des enfants dans
les conflits armés
je vous avais informé de mes travaux sur
le sujet des enfants sans identité de la
mobilisation des acteurs dans le monde
et de la nécessité d'un engagement de la
france sur ce sujet aujourd'hui un quart
des enfants de moins de cinq ans ne sont
pas enregistrés à la naissance dans le
monde et la france n'est pas exemple du
problème en particulier à mayotte qui a
été évoqué cet après midi ce sont 166
millions d'enfants de moins de cinq ans
qui n'ont pas d'existence légale qui
sont ainsi privés des droits
élémentaires et les victimes des pires
abus le problème est bien identifié
géographe y est les causes sont connues
les solutions existent c'est ce que
rapportent nos travaux menés avec ma
collègue nina kuryk lors dans le cadre
d'une mission de la commission des
affaires étrangères rapport qui a été
adoptée à l'unanimité le 22 septembre
dernier
alors monsieur méniscale france a un
rôle à jouer dans ce domaine au niveau
national dans sa politique bilatérale
l'aide au développement et au sein des
instances internationales dans
lesquelles elle siège nous avons décliné
23 propositions votre ministère est en
première ligne pour agir sur le sujet
dès maintenant nous comptons sur vous en
effet faire que chaque enfant
conte est une nécessité pour l'adulte
qu'il deviendra pour son pays qui doit
savoir qu'il existe et pour la
communauté internationale dans laquelle
il pourra être amené à se déplacer un
jour vous connaissez mon engagement sur
ce sujet je ne doute pas du vôtre pour
défendre une si grande cause je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues à aynac urique
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre la situation est plus que
critique en ce moment même à madagascar
en particulier au sud de lille qui a
fait la une du journal de l'île de la
réunion cette semaine et qui a provoqué
une vive émotion
si la région du sud de madagascar est
habitué aux grosses chaleurs et la
sécheresse l'année 2020 s'annonce
particulièrement destructrices et la
famine gangrène cette région ce
phénomène de sécheresse et de faim
traditionnellement appelée le quéré dure
depuis près d'un an en janvier 2017 d'un
million de personnes manquaient d'eau
potable à madagascar et près de 850
mille personnes étaient en situation
d'insécurité alimentaire sévère dans le
sud du pays des chiffres importants qui
traduisent la difficulté du pays à faire
face au phénomène climatique et au delà
des images inquiétantes qui ont été
diffusés cette semaine l'annoncé du
décès de huit enfants pour cause de
famille interpelle en espérant que cela
soit toujours le cas l'assemblée
nationale devrait prochainement étudié
la loi d'orientation et de programmation
relative à la politique de développement
et de solidarité internationale dans
laquelle une liste de 19 pays de l'aide
publique au développement compte
madagascar la question est donc la
suivante où en sommes-nous concernant la
stratégie de développement à madagascar
notamment à travers la loppsi et quels
sont les domaines dans lesquels la
france va concentrer ses efforts en
matière des publics au développement sur
le sol malgache je vous remercie
merci beaucoup cher collègue nicolas
dupont aignan merci monsieur le ministre
très brièvement d'abord merci de passer
autant de temps avec nous question sur
le haut-karabagh ce conflit entre
l'azerbaïdjan et l'arménie
car au delà de ce conflit entre ces deux
pays
c'est quand même l'intervention turque
avéré forte qui dope l'azerbaïdjan et
qui pose un problème pas seulement
politique mais morale car c'est quand
même la turquie commis un génocide
contre les arméniens donc la solidarité
de la france à l'égard de des arméniens
devrait nous conduire à passer peut-être
à des menaces plus précises vis-à-vis de
la turquie et j'en viens à ma question
principale
on a eu la sphère en syrie
l'interventionnisme turc on a eu le
massacre des kurdes
on à la campagne dans les eaux
chypriotes grecs
on a le transfert de mercenaires en
libye on a maintenant une intervention
très précise des turcs dans le
haut-karabagh est ce que à un moment
donné les pays de l'union européenne
vous avez parlé du sommet et vous avez
parlé de décembre quelles sont
concrètement du prochain sommet de
décembre et que vous attendiez quelles
sont concrètement les actes qui vont
aller au delà des paroles et quand je le
vois l'interview ce soir du président de
la cds ou qui se permet de dire que la
france en gros n'a rien fait sur la fère
russe et quand on sait le double jeu que
joue l'allemagne en matière turc est ce
qu'à un moment le président de la
république ne devrait pas dire sa vérité
à madame merkel et demander plus de
solidarité de l'allemagne dans cette
affaire merci chers collègues bruno
fuchs on a je rappelle qu'on a très peu
dans le ministre doit partir à 17h30
merci monsieur le président monsieur
ministre merci pour différentes
interventions et à vos côtés je voulais
saluer l'intervention de la france et
les positions fortes prises sur le liban
prises également sur la biélorussie et
d'autres dossiers
il ya des situations en revanche qui ont
été abordés déjà notamment en afrique
sur lesquels la police la france
pourrait peut-être être être précisées
on a parlé du cameroun vous l'avez effet
le domicile de maurice kamto est
encerclé par des forces de l'ordre
depuis maintenant trois semaines sans
qu'il puisse sortir qu'on puisse lui
apporter des vivres
il ya un nombre très important
d'arrestations également le 22 septembre
plus de centaines de manifestants
arrêtés
est ce que la france est intervenue ou
peut intervenir sur des situations de
cette nature en côte d'ivoire vous
souhaitez une élection apaisée et
inclusive
est ce que le 31 octobre vous pensez
qu'avec deux candidats des députés
encore emprisonnés et puis une
interdiction de manifester dans les rues
d'abidjan
les conditions d'une élection apaisée et
inclusif sont réunis et puis la question
également que je vais pas développer en
guinée avec des élections le 18 octobre
où là encore il est en guinée conakry
la situation est là aussi extrêmement
tendue
merci chers collègues
juste à titre de rappel il reste huit
interventions je sais pas si on va y
arriver
alors je vais laisser je m'entretiens
avait pour être très clair que ces
irakiens
je ne peux pas lui dire on va prendre
une dernière question le coin d'une
dernière question jacques maire merci je
vais la faire extrêmement rapide
monsieur le ministre
d'abord monsieur mettre une question
courte on a appris avec un immense
soulagement
je veux parler de l'otage sophie petrona
nous avons appris un immense soulagement
hier soir qu'elle serait libérée avec
l'opposant malien souleymane cissé dans
les heures qui viennent
les heures passent et la libération
semble tarder faut-il s'inquiéter
monsieur le ministre monsieur mer je
commence par cela parce que je suis en
public ça fait plus de huit ans que j'ai
à traiter des affaires d'otages
jamais je n'ai évoqué ces questions en
public ni en privé et toutes les
questions d'otages sont réglées dans un
cercle extrêmement restreint y compris
dans mon propre entourage
et donc c'est pas aujourd'hui je vais
recommencer et je pense que vous devriez
les uns et les autres méditer sur cette
posture vous pouvez enchaîner monsieur
le ministre
et
ah oui elle est annoncée parquet de
paris donc je maintiens ma réponse voilà
après vous parlez faites ce que vous
voulez moi voilà ma position je le fais
ça que sur un seul sujet aimé y compris
des sujets qui vous ont concerné dans le
passé gayraud kg abouti des résultats
alors je ne sais pas si je reprendrai je
reprendrai la semaine prochaine de
donner les éléments que vous avez évoqué
les uns et les autres j'ai peut-être pas
pouvoir tout reprendre tout est
peut-être que je suis tenté de faire une
des considérations générales sur deux
sujets majeurs que vous avez qui se
croisent par rapport à tout ce que vous
avez dit les uns les autres
excusez moi de me mettre un nom sur les
questions posées il faut qu'il y ait
avec la turquie une grande clarification
et générer 10 à plusieurs reprises nous
avons des sujets irritent ans voire
conflictuelles qui s'accumulent ya la
question libyenne où il ya une présence
militaire turque très significative qui
nous interpelle nous interroge il y à la
question syrienne à la fois dans le
nord-est et dans le nord-ouest deux
postures différentes mais qui ont abouti
à des postures agressives à l'égard de
nos propres lectures parcours en
particulier les fds dans la partie
nord-ouest
vous avez la question irakienne c'est
gai nouvelle mais il se trouve que les
les turcs sont maintenant présents
militairement dans le nord- irak et dans
la partie du nord kurdistan irakien vous
avez la question du haut karabagh vous
avez la question de la méditerranée
orientale
ça commence à faire beaucoup et donc
voilà il ya plusieurs questions là
dessus et je peux jouer et dont il faut
que nous ayons avec la turquie à
dialogue un dialogue mais de grande
clarification
le président a rappelé que s'est
entretenu avec monsieur erdogan le ya
quelques jours je vais m'entretenir
prochainement avec mon collègue j'avoue
que je loue quelqu'un me demandait quel
était l'état de nos relations chez plus
je crois que c'est vous-même tresseur
avec mon collègue turc
disons que les 10 mais pour l'instant la
relation et tonique
on peut dire ça comme ça parce que je
suis un public différent mais mais mais
donc je pense que c'est indispensable
mais pour mener ce dialogue fort
il faut que l'union européenne soit unie
faut que nos partenaires européens
soient dans la même dynamique nous avons
une position plus affirmée dans la
discussion
donc non moins pour des tas de raisons
que ce n'est pour tenir a évoqué mais
que les uns les autres connaissent bien
le flux migratoire l'histoire tout ça
nous tout simplement
et la présence de populations turques
sur tel ou tel territoire et proximité
géographique bref il ya un ensemble de
choses mais nous avons toujours tenu à
voir nous une position très ferme et
demande de clarification et je pense que
au dernier conseil européen puisqu'il
faisait suite à une réunion préparatoire
des ministres à faire des affaires
étrangères à bruxelles d'un des conseils
repères on a abouti à une posture je
crois très significatif sur un sujet sur
le sujet de la méditerranée orientale où
il a été dit mais je les dis en
commençant mon propos que si d'aventuré
n'y avait pas l'engagement de
discussions et le retrait des deux
des bateaux turcs de la zone chypriote
et grecque d'ici conseil de descendre
des sanctions seraient initiés par le
conseil européen à l'unanimité des 27
c'est la première fois que des choses
sont dites avec autant de fermeté de
clarté donc il importe que les turcs eux
puisse engager ces discussions sinon on
sera dans une dans une logique de
conflit tu alité virtuel avec des cubes
déshéritant permanent dans cette
relation il fut un temps où il y avait
un dialogue mais là il ya une somme
d'initiatives une somme de fait accompli
parce que c'est la garde et sûrs que
monsieur de cloche que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure les fait accompli un engrenage
de fait accompli qui devient
insupportable
donc c'est ça qui est sur la table si on
y va seul dans ce set discussions forte
qu'il faut avoir de clarification ça
n'aboutira pas suffisamment il faut
conditions à 27 et que les vingt-sept
disent la même chose ce qu'on a fait la
dernière fois et c d avance alors chacun
apportant sa propre inflexion sur la
discussion mais ça oblige
obligatoirement les la turquie a bougé
sur cette espèce d'expansionnisme tous
azimuts il développe actuellement et il
ya aussi le doigt que je veux mettre sur
une nouvelle donne qui vous est apparu
je suis un peu de la géopolitique là
mais je veux - - sur les juges elle une
nouvelle donne qui vous est apparu
certainement c'est d'aider des
situations cumulé de confit qualité
potentiel entre la turquie et la russie
honnêtement quand en 2017 que j'ai
commencé mes fonctions s'il n'existait
pas vous avez ces situations de
confiture alité potentiel en libye vous
avez cette situation de confidentialité
potentiel en série et vous avez
maintenant cette situation conflictuelle
culte et potentiels au haut karabagh
c'est une nouvelle donne de la
géopolitique qui contribuent occupation
aux instabilités que nous nous
constatons je voulais vous dire ça
puisque j'ai ça me fait partie de d'une
synthèse des discussions convient
d'avoir je voudrais vous redire une
deuxième chose puisque monsieur monsieur
herbillon va poser des questions juste
j'ai pas goûté vous dire maintenant je
vous ai félicités de thaler monsieur
lecoq
mais avant félicitations les les sorties
de crise en fait elles elles sont
relativement elles sont relativement
simple pour nous en ce qui concerne la
libye par exemple on sait très bien ce
qu'il faut faire il faut qu'il y ait le
ccl gellée dit d'ailleurs seul le
cessez-le-feu ce 30 l'attrait se
transforme en cessez-le-feu dans le
cadre du comité militaire 5 + 5 puis
parallèlement à cela on refait marché le
block ford et on débloque le blocus
pétroliers ont refait marché l'économie
libyenne et on engage un processus
politique qui passe par des élections
par une réforme de la constitution
c'est ça tout le monde d'accord sur ça
le seul problème de la diplomatie que
pal pas de la nôtre mais la diplomatie
des à des uns et les autres c'est
comment ces principes là on les met en
oeuvre comme on embraye et ça c'est
compliqué la libye ce tout le monde
voilà c'est notre position c'est la
position des italiens des allemands des
ions de la communauté internationale
quand on prend chacun des sujets on voit
ce qu'il faut faire sur la belarusse
puisque des questions et hérons et ont
été posées que pense que je devrais dire
que ceux qui s'y intéressent et qui ont
eu madame ciccone cia ce matin plus on
en parle mieux on se porte
et plus il ya de pression de
manifestations et si vous voulez y aller
aller si je sais pas si vous serez
accepter ça c'est une autre paire de
manches mais je peux faire une halte si
vous voulez monsieur lukashenko je suis
pas sûr qu'elle sera validée mais mais
mais mais ça vaut le coup mais sur la
bélarusse on voit bien puisque c'est pas
une question géopolitique ça vous a été
dit par madame cascadia ce matin comme
il nous l'a dit
devant les hors pair il ya quelques
jours et devant le président de la
république
c'est une question de démocratie interne
et de ce site d'inclusivité de la suite
de la médiation question de médiation il
faut de nouveau de nouvelles élections
et il faut des acteurs pour la médiation
on sait qu elle l acteur potentiel de la
médiation c'est de la bce
c'est fait pour ça on parti et les
russes n'y sont pas opposés mais il faut
que monsieur lukashenko la proue c'est
ça la sortie de crise et après processus
électoral et puis oublié et puis voilà
la bélarusse reste dans son indépendance
sur le liban on connaît le processus
un gouvernement de transition de 18 mois
à peu près puis des élections
législatives mais dans la tente il faut
une liste de mesures qui soient mises en
oeuvre qui sont partagées par la
communauté internationale entre hier bah
quand je réunis dans le cadre du du gers
appel du groupement de soutien livre au
liban je tiens le jce liban quand
j'aurai ni l'ensemble des acteurs ils
sont tous quasiment tous là tout le
monde dit la même chose tout le monde il
faut réformer la banque du liban il faut
réformer système des marchés publics il
faut une loi contre la corruption il ya
dix 10 choses à faire qui redonnerait
confiance à la communauté internationale
qui à ce moment là commencera aider le
liban à agir sinon le fera pas personne
ne le fera
on connaît la sortie de fait il ya
quelques azim ans sur tous les sujets on
s'aime il faut aller et notre rôle
mon rôle le rôle de la diplomatie
c'était d'avoir autour de soi
suffisamment nombreux pour pousser pour
dire forêt dans ce sens la folie dans ce
sens là n'ont pas le pouvoir de faire on
va le faire par la force
on a vu ce que ça donne de faire par la
force et donc il faut le faire par la
persuasion et et la négociation sur le
haut-karabagh c'est pareil sans doute
doit sans doute paye ton je pense le
fait que nous n'avons pas été les uns
les autres j'ai dit tout à l'heure à ses
actifs dans la discussion entre les
azéris et les arméniens sur en
particulier sur les districts qui ont
tourné le haut karabakh
au sud et ouest est
mais bon maintenant il faut se mettre
autour d'une table et discuter voilà ce
que je voulais vous dire sur sur les
grands sujets évoqués de manière ou
d'une manière générale alors après dans
les détails monsieur bah je suis
d'accord sur l'idée d'un sur la mise en
oeuvre d'un dispositif de protection des
humanitaires j'ai déjà dit aux nations
unies et nous sommes tout à fait
partisan d'utiliser vos réflexions pour
aboutir à cela et nous allons agir en ce
sens pour réunir une conférence
humanitaire il est où là monsieur de
bail pour nous allons réunir une
conférence nationale humanitaires avant
la fin de l'année je vais me rendre
d'ailleurs très prochainement au niger
mais le niger est aussi soumis à des
élections
prochainement il n'empêche que cette
initiative est une initiative tout à
fait opportune et je dis aussi tant que
j'y suis à ma dame du mont que si elle
m'entend toujours et amada maric qui a
cure et kia qui a participé que le
travail que vous avez effectué sur la
commandite comment dire la paire hâtif
de l'état civil et est un travail
essentiel nous y avons travaillé nous
avons bien noté les propositions que
vous faites pour notre propre compte
mais ça fait partie du droit essentiel
des enfants mais de chacun de chaque
individu d'avoir un état civil c'est
c'est le début de ces le début tout est
si on n'a pas d'aidé de l'état civil en
aidant dans la percussion vaude rapports
le montrent non je serai très attentif à
ce sujet qui me préoccupe beaucoup je
voulais vous le dire ici nous nous
travaillons tout à fait dans cette
direction
pour monsieur quentin il ya le processus
de nouméa
il se déroule nous aurons sans doute une
autre élection dans un délai de 18 mois
quelque chose comme ça 2 o mais après ça
les textes qua non mais c'est pas des
idées il est possible qu'ils aient il
est possible qu'il y est mais c'est
indépendant de notre relation avec
l'australie et avec la nouvelle zélande
même si il s'intéresse beaucoup aux
résultats de cette élection nous sommes
sur le renforcement de la stratégie indo
pacifique
pour répondre à votre question c'est le
discours du président macron à canberra
non à sydney au début de son mandat et
nous constatons à de plus en plus de
soutien pour cette logique indo
pacifique
l'allemagne elle même vient de faire un
projet stratégique sur l'action qu'elle
peut mener dans l'espace un taux
pacifique les australiens sont très
soucieux de slam et l'inde aussi le
japon était aussi intéressé bref il ya
toute une
un ensemble d'acteurs qui veulent
travailler dans cette direction et nous
en sommes très heureux
j'ai répondu là j'ai pas répondu à gaz
car pour madame curé que nous avons bien
conscience des des risques qui ont le
dieu à madagascar je me suis rendu à
madagascar il n'y a pas très longtemps
nous avons renforcé notre coopération et
notre développement avec ce pays
je me suis rendu à madagascar après un
long moment de d'absence de pour des
raisons propres à madagascar où la
france hésité à faire le déplacement
c'est un peu proche de à peu près les
mêmes problématiques au cameroun
n'allez pas parce que nous n'allions pas
la certitude d'avoir les interlocuteurs
qui convenait au sens noble du terme
ce n'est plus le cas puisque les
élections présidentielles et nous allons
mobiliser 50 millions d'euros profil
madagascar en matière d aide au
développement
la relation a été très très positive
même s'il ya parfois il ya des sujets de
contentieux avec madagascar je pense aux
elysées par son particulier mais il
n'empêche que la relation est devenue
excellente et ce qui se passe dans la
partie sud de madagascar est très très
préoccupant il ya aussi une prise de
conscience du potentiel d'eau bien dire
de biodiversité du pays par le président
de madagascar qui est très très soucieux
de cette nécessité de lutter contre la
déforestation
et donc c'est d'un pays
qu'il faut encourager qui est proche de
la france et qui est un vrai partenaire
potentiel l'un là parce que je crois que
je dis à tous sur les sur les comores je
crois que j'avais répondu tout à l'heure
madame ann lee sur madame madame le pen
sur les fragiles ou codes de loukachenko
je crois que j'ai répondu tout à l'heure
sur ce sujet c'est en essayant de
montrer la l'intérêt international sur
la situation du mouvement est initiée
par le peuple de la bélarusse et est
tout à fait essentiel et nous ne
reconnaîtrons pas la légitimité de
monsieur lukashenko tu donc il n'a plus
l'utilité politique à l'extérieur ce qui
devient très très difficile qui peut
devenir très difficile pot pour lui et
il faut donc faire en sorte que nous
agissions par la pression mais nous
agissons aussi par les sanctions
quarante personnalités bélarusses qui
vont faire le plein de sanctions à la
fois sur leurs avoirs à l'étranger et
sur le rhin possibilité de voyager c'est
ça les sanctions ça veut dire qu'on ne
peut pas voyager quand on a de l'argent
placé ailleurs ce qui est souvent le cas
on l'a pas c'est quand même très
pénalisant pour pour ces acteurs là sur
les comores je crois que j'ai répondu
dans la réponse 2 que j'avais fait tout
à l'heure à l'interlocuteur précédent
sur le la mise en oeuvre de l'accord du
22 juillet c'est vrai qu'il ya des
difficultés a eu des difficultés je le
dis à mme adama ly le liées
essentiellement aux en grande partie pas
essentiellement aux coronavirus en
particulier sur les reconduites
2 les opérations de reconduites les
comores ayant fermé leurs frontières aux
mondiaux de la de lakovic 19 c'est la
situation s est améliorée et nous
essayons d'être faire en sorte que les
engagements qui ont été annoncées soient
tenus par les autorités comoriennes
il y aura un réunion du comité de haut
niveau de suivi de l'accord dans les
jours qui viennent avec la participation
des élus de mayotte et donc nous verrons
si il faut donner des inflexions
nécessaires à cet accord mais c'était
d'accord c'est un accord très important
parce qu'il n'avait jamais eu lieu de
cette manière on a mis du temps à le
signer mais on l'a signé à paris au mois
de mai dernier
j'ai dit côte d'ivoire déjà j'ai déjà
répondu sur la côte d'ivoire si je le
connais personnellement je ne suis allé
au cameroun que lorsqu'il a été libéré
il le sait je sais je sais gré vous
voulez quoi que j'aille le voir mais on
l'a déjà exprimé publiquement
moi je suis allé le voir monsieur conto
shenzhen veut non mais je suis j'ai dit
monsieur j'ai dit aux autorités
camerounaises que générer au cameroun
que lorsque monsieur comme tous les
livres et j'ai respecté mon engagement
et sur la côte d'ivoire sur la côte
d'ivoire je ne crois monsieur foot que
j'ai rappelé tout à l'heure notre souci
d'être très vigilants sur l'impartialité
du scrutin donc souhaitons que ça se
passe dans les meilleures conditions de
calme que les habitants de la côte
d'ivoire puisse s'exprimer très
librement
la seule chose que je puisse dire à
l'heure actuelle
voilà merci pour l'instant je continue
la semaine prochaine merci monsieur le
ministre merci à vous chers collègues et
encore désolé pour les collègues qui
n'ont pas pu prendre la parole le
ministre nous invite à reposer les
questions la semaine prochaine donc
voilà
je vous invite à le faire merci à vous
chers collègues et merci monsieur le
ministre d'avoir répondu à toutes nos
questions que mercy en ce sens étant
publique je peux pas dire plus